there's a big story out of Loudoun
County and for those that don't know we
actually live literally next door to
Loudoun County if we hop out the front
door and go down the road a little bit
we will be in Loudoun County there's
been parents standing up against
critical theory meaning critical race
Theory and critical gender Theory as
well as mask mandates and vaccine
mandates things like that of course as
you probably heard the AG has been
targeting these parents saying that this
stuff is potentially domestic Terror
things of that nature these are just
parents standing for their kids well
there was a big Scandal and we talked
about the story yesterday on timcast.com
not because we were concerned about
censorship but because we thought you
know maybe maybe a little bit but we
were like this one can get spicy and if
we want to you know be less family
friendly considering these issues are
very very serious and unfamily friendly
then we'll take it to the Tim guest.com
is a more serious segment and we did
but just before we were starting the
show
um I got a message from Stephen Crowder
he's been he's been given a hard strike
and a suspension over covering the
scandal in Loudoun County and we have a
redacted email breaking down what
YouTube is is accusing him of doing and
this means that they're not going to be
able to do their show normally because
they're suspended from YouTube for the
next week so of course uh we're big fans
you guys definitely want to check out
lotterwithcrowder.com make sure you guys
are supporting the best of your
abilities with the mug club and uh
Steven tells me they're gonna be doing
their show on their website as they have
in the past because of the strike that
being said we're going to get into this
news we've got a bunch of other stories
pertaining to wokeness and what's going
on and we're gonna have to be really
careful in how we describe the story and
we're gonna be starting with what got
Crowder banned so that we can then talk
about the con certain context of that
story and yes we might get banned too
but let me just stress as we are here
facing down the barrel of censorship we
are actively resisting it by showing you
what's happening to those being censored
talking about the context and providing
the Speakeasy over at timcast.com where
you can make sure that these ideas will
will persist in the face of massive
corporate power
we are being joined today by of course
Jack Murphy Tim I'm so glad to be back
Ian Luke Lydia how are you I am Jack
Murphy you can follow me on Jack at Jack
Murphy live on Twitter but more
importantly please come down and meet me
at a whole crew of people at jacked
brunch we just had one in Tampa it was
amazing we had a bunch of people
families children wives it's not just
all men because you know about the
liminal order it's all men we're doing
Nashville two weeks on 10 24 so come on
down and see me there we're gonna do one
in DC you guys are all coming you gonna
come too in February put it on the
counter gonna be huge happy to be back
beautiful Studio I got dressed up a
little bit sharp to help Christen the
new beautiful gorgeous studio right I'm
happy to be here thanks for having me
what's your name again Jack's dressed
for prom over here prom and then maybe
I'll go to your event I don't know I
haven't decided yet but anyway
what happened to Crowder is absolutely
disturbing while I still have a channel
it is youtube.com forward slash we are
change and of course I have an
alternative to YouTube where I get to do
and say whatever I want and that of
course is Luke uncensored.com I hope to
see you guys later on there today and
thanks for having me yeah I'm happy to
be back as well sorry Jack I was about
to I was gonna say I bet you wore that
to prom too
that's a nice shirt by the way Lou thank
you oh yeah the shirt here is uh you
know just some immune system deniers and
uh has a nice portrait of Mr Bill Gates
and Lord well uh you know my name is Ian
cross I'm also glad you're here Jack I
like uh you look very slim and trim in
your new outfit thank you so much so
happy to be here everyone hello I love
you I love your sweater thanks dude good
job sweaters very good yeah I'm also
here pushing buttons I'm getting better
and better pushing all these new camera
buttons so I hope you guys will continue
to bear with me since we have such a big
show tonight I was listening to Crowder
early today and I'm curious what uh ends
up happening with him yeah this is this
is weird because we'll read the email
we'll show you exactly what they're
accusing Crowder of doing because I'm
kind of like it seems weird but we'll
get into it before we do we have a
sponsor today my friends biotrusts multi
I'm sorry ageless multi-collagen head
over to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can get
51 off of your supply of ageless
multi-collagen today as a 35 year old
man who skates all the time I know full
well that my knees need support but this
stuff is good for your skin for your
bones and a lot of people take collagen
supplements I certainly recommend this
one Ian's always putting this yeah I
would love to put actually yeah every
show he does and I'm like let's just do
it we're doing the promo but this is
good stuff
make sure your skin your joints your
nails everything is doing better you
could get the supplement over at
strongerbones in life.com and BioTrust
says you'll get a 60-day money-back
guarantee the healthy aging support of
collagen in its ideal forms the five key
types of collagen you need from four
different sources essential to optimally
support an array of Full Body Benefits
hydrolyzed collagen peptides meaning
better and faster digestibility to
support maximum benefits for every order
today they will donate a nutritious meal
to a hungry child in your honor for
their partnership with no kidhungry.org
to date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids please help
BioTrust hit their goal of six million
meals this year it's non-GMO and free of
artificial colors flavors or
preservatives sweeteners it's
gluten-free no antibiotics and no rbgh
and RBST nearly no odor or taste unlike
bone broth there's no clumping unlike
other collagen supplements you'll get
free shipping with every order free VIP
live health and fitness coaching from
BioTrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their new e-report 14 foods for
amazing skin with every order again that
is stronger bones in life special shout
out to BioTrust and all of the companies
that sponsor shows like this considering
we are literally talking about a major
story in censorship my respect to
companies like BioTrust I have a
question about BioTrust you just sold me
actually did I yeah uh Red Hen my fiance
she's a hair stylist in the beauty
industry and she's always talking about
collagen she's taking collagen I think I
need to get some of this do I need like
a promo code or anything there isn't you
just go to strongerbones in life.com all
right I'm on it look at this guy helping
our sponsor out with a good old no but
it's actually true I'm actually I'm
going to hook that up because I'm 45 now
and I got to maintain the collagen in my
cheeks it goes good in water too yeah
just mix it into water so I'm not going
to mix it into this Scotch though no I
don't think it goes into Scotch I've
never tried you got two nice little
cocktails going on yeah you know there's
a bar and a bartender downstairs now and
every time I walk in the guy's like
hello sir what can I get for you yeah
we're getting a little fancy my friends
don't forget to go to timcast.com become
a member while the member segment coming
after the show and I have an
announcement uh look my apologies to
everybody who is a member um we
announced that for our Live Events we've
been trying to set them up consistently
like we want to do an event every month
and at the studio but red tape
um there's there's legal restrictions
for very simple things like a private
residence versus a business versus how
you can invite people in and so we're
getting it was difficult but we booked a
venue and we put up for so as I said
those who are giving at least 25 bucks
or more will get advanced notice of the
event we put it up and it sold out
nearly instantly so the tickets are free
every everyone gets a plus one there's
200 available and some people were upset
because they were emailing us saying
like this should have been up for us the
25 members before everyone else and it
literally was it's just that we have a
lot of members but we are going to do
our best to make sure we can accommodate
everybody and you know the members who
are at the 25 level who tried to get in
and maybe didn't make it in time we're
gonna we're gonna try and work something
out with like a waiting list if you end
up showing up and there's capacity
availability we'll let people in I don't
want to encourage people to show up in
the event that they don't get in but my
apologies to those who couldn't get it
look I wish we could do it you know as
many people as possible but not only is
it going to be the entire crew there
where we have we have Ryan long and uh
and Danny polishuk who are going to be
doing the the comedy act for the night
so you know I'm talking to Ryan and he's
like dude we we'd sell out a show like
with 200 tickets instantly if we were
doing it by ourselves like and I'm like
yeah so if we have all of this as a big
event it's going to be pretty hard to
get a ticket considering we're not doing
a major venue maybe we should do a
thousand person venue this time 100 and
let's hit the road and do live shows and
every major city that we go to maybe we
should actually start looking for a
venue that can accommodate up to a
thousand people exactly and then maybe
we'll change venues or big parks or you
know we can do music performance and
sound systems and then that but we'll
we'll see about maybe upgrading the
venue if that works because I'm honestly
I can't believe we just instantly people
are hungry for Live Events Tim that's
why we're doing jack brunch we're just
going around every two weeks a different
city a Sunday brunch open Mimosa bar
Great Buffet come down and hang out and
you know I'm Jack Murphy but you're a
temple of course you're going to be
drawing all kinds of people well there
are some people who are like they just
missed it and we we obviously didn't set
capacity as the limit for the tickets
because you can't because there's going
to be security there might be you know
staff and stuff like that but we might
have a few extra tickets for people who
have already emailed to try and make
sure we can get as many people as
possible maybe you'll find a bigger
venue we'll see we can do let's put them
on the lawn right here outside let's do
the mega so we wanted to do a lot we
can't that's the problem we literally
wanted to be like you know come hang out
we can't there's no parking lots
there's just a lot of things I can't get
into I'm excited to make everyone chant
let's go Brandon it's going to be a lot
of fun the energy is going to be really
good I love events I love t-shirts out
front no yes like pictures maybe of it
online and like cryptocurrencies but uh
otherwise no no
let's talk about this year news we got
uh so uh I got a text message just a
moment ago literally if you within a few
minutes of going live in the show from
Crowder and he was just like telling me
what happened and the story is
absolutely insane you may have heard
about the Loudon County Scandal where
there was a student who was uh harmed
their an arrest was made and I I can't I
didn't realize this because we were
actually we actually talked about this a
little bit yesterday uh during the show
but apparently
telling the context of this major
breaking news story which is having a
serious effect on how the AG is acting
and responding to parents Crowder got a
strike over this they've suspended him
for a week and I have this email check
this out
this is this is what uh YouTube has
written
we write again on YouTube's behalf
regarding I'm sorry I believe this is
their legal counsel we write again on
YouTube's behalf regarding your client
Stephen Crowder YouTube has repeatedly
instructed Mr Crowder regarding its hate
speech policy and warned him against
continuing violations of that policy
through content he uploaded to YouTube
YouTube specifically informed Mr Crowder
that videos he uploaded show a pattern
of recklessly targeting the lgbtq plus
Community for abuse and insults it
warned that further uploading of content
that targets insults and or abuses the
lgbtq community would result in
additional penalties on September 30th
Mr Crowder uploaded another video that
YouTube has determined continues his
prior conduct the video entitled special
guest Alex Jones on great reset and Joe
Rogan triggers left us again contains a
segment that targets the transgender
community in a defensive manner for
example by indicating that trans people
pose a rape threat to women consistent
with the recklessness provision of its
hate speech Policy YouTube has removed
this video from the service and assessed
a strike against the Stephen Crowder
Channel for our YouTube strikes policy
this results in a one-week upload freeze
for the channel further violation of
YouTube's hate speech policy will result
in additional penalties one additional
note when an account is restricted from
using YouTube features the channel
operator is prohibited from using any
other channel to get around the
applicable restrictions your client may
not use another YouTube channel such as
crowderbit's channel to bypass the
upload restrictions on the Stephen
Crowder Channel such conduct May subject
all of his channels to termination very
truly yours Council for YouTube
now I don't know exactly what Stephen
said or how he framed it but I cannot
imagine
that it would warrant a takedown it's a
major breaking story
I think it's it's particularly dangerous
that we're in an era now where opinions
are editorial there's an editorial
guideline for for big services that you
are not allowed to express yourself
online if your opinion doesn't fall in
line with the editorial guidelines of
YouTube you know this is disturbing on
many levels because this is about a
specific documented case when children
got hurt I mean this is a big case this
deserves to be talked about but it can't
and what Crowder said I don't know I
don't I don't watch him I've been
critical of him before but to have his
voice kind of eliminated here is a very
big deal there deserves to be a
conversation that it deserves to be some
kind of debate here and we're being
denied that people are not hearing about
this very important story which they
should uh and and that to me is the
biggest travesty of Injustice personally
because at the same time crowded as his
show whether you like it or not you have
to understand the mainstream media gets
away with showing horrible stuff on
YouTube whether it's Gore whether it's
it's stories that are more hyperbolic
more sense stational more gross more
detailed and and and they got caught
many times lying through their teeth let
me I want to say two quick things for
one you guys louder with crowder.com you
can join the mug Club you can help
support them they're going to be doing
their show on their website this is why
we have the websites this is why
Crowder's got his website that's why we
got our website so that in the event
maybe we'll get a strike for simply
talking about this and me reading what
the email said and that's why we have
the website up so that we can at least
have something active in the event week
we get hit by YouTube but we're not
going to just sit back and accept it so
the story is very simple there was in
Loudoun County a father this is the
daily y reporting this News Guard
certified all that good stuff reporting
that a child was assaulted will keep the
language family friendly but it was in a
bathroom and there was an arrest made
Crowder talked about the story to be
fair I don't know exactly how he framed
it but still regardless this is a major
breaking news story we have more
developments developments on this that
we're going to be talking about and I
think it's particularly dangerous
we are enter what more needs to be said
that you haven't heard me say 50 billion
times when you homogenize the political
space you don't end the opinions of
these people they exist they're alive
they're going to live for for 50 more
years
between you know how how old are the
people who are paying attention paying
attention to politics right now let's
say they're 18 to to 70. okay so we're
gonna have a long period of people
holding these views they want to express
censoring them just makes them find
alternative means Crowder of course
isn't going anywhere he's going to keep
doing his show his show on his own
platform all YouTube is doing is hyper
polarizing the space by shutting down
these conversations what I think is
interesting one is that apparently two
Spirits are full or fair game because
it's not listed it's not listed up there
uh but second is this is this is the end
result of what's been happening for many
years where you turn uh an insult into
abuse right it says abuse and insults
like how are those even the same things
abuse is chronic ongoing and it
prohibits you from doing the thing that
you're supposed to do whether it's live
life or have a job or get education an
insult is just part of life right it's a
part of life so what they're saying now
is that they're they're criminalizing
bombing effectively or prohibiting
insults it sounds like but they didn't
even name who these are minors and other
names are released this is not targeting
any specific apparently it's just making
an insult about the lgbtq plus Community
they were saying it's repetitive insults
which I guess you could consider abuse
no no abuse abuse has to has to prevent
you from doing something that you
ordinarily would want to do like live a
healthy productive life hold on see the
problem with that is they argue when I'm
insulted I get scared and I shut down so
like their delicacy is not my concern
right this is like second and third
order effects of us transitioning away
from an honor culture to a victim
culture we're victim victimology gives
you status and so now you can claim
status by being first it was abused then
it was harassed now it's insulted and
soon it'll be even been thought
improperly but nobody I'm sorry I'm
sorry nobody complained about this so
this must have been somebody internal
right right right I I don't think
Crowder I don't think any individual was
named in this story well again it says
about the community itself so you can't
even insult like if Dave Chappelle came
in here and did one of his bits they'd
get your show taken down right yep yeah
which is crazy because I don't know Dave
Chappelle never seemed to be too far
outside if CNN came here and did a
segment this channel would be terminated
immediately for like half of their
content that they put out there that's
deemed again just based out other lives
that would be the one time we appear on
the front page yeah they'd be like see
we're fair look the Tim cast irl's on
the front page I'm like yeah cause Don
Lemon was the guest I would love I would
love to have Don Lemon I would love to
have Anderson Cooper I had many
interactions with him in parking lots
that were pretty interesting to say the
least wait did you say parking lots I
almost made a joke that might get the
chance
I actually would would love to have a
sit down conversation with Anderson
Cooper hell yeah bring them on it'll be
extremely entertaining to say the least
my conversations with them were pretty
entertaining already but but again
there's this duplicity here there's this
hypocrisy here because again they're
playing by different rules I I think
that you know the Independent Community
is being micromanaged to the point of
absurdity there's there's these rules
and there's these unspoken rules we
don't know the exact circumstances but
but where do you draw the line when
talking about documented specific cases
and stories about actual victims that
need to be heard I mean imagine being
this girl or this father already uh we
can't even get into the details here but
but there is allegations of of cover-up
already happening now this is happening
on top of that imagine being such a
victim to the point where your story
can't even get out there to the general
public no one should even hear your
story that to me is even the bigger
crime here this is this like the it's
look
it sounds Soviet I I have uh there's a
friend of mine that I've known for years
that I've hung out with in various
countries was from Ukraine and these are
the stories that I would hear about you
know when you when to be fair like the
Soviet Union collapsed when we were kids
but to be like oh yeah this is my this
is what my parents warned me about this
is what they said how it started and
this is what they were scared of it's
things like this certain things aren't
allowed to be talked about just like the
story itself can't be talked about the
concerns the parents can't be talking
about it's weird because it's YouTube is
kind of like a common space now because
it's supposedly it's still a private
company but a common carrier like going
out in the street and talking in the
middle of the road with your friends in
Poland information against the state was
criminalized if you gave out flyers and
pamphlets that were went against the
State win against the commies uh you
would get jail time you'd get put into
the prison camps some people would get
tortured for simply just expressing
political ideas and I think this is not
we're not at that level yet but we're at
a moment where it could be a very easy
slippery slope and also when I mean
parking lots with Anderson Cooper don't
get ideas like dirty-minded Jack here
you know you can see the videos you can
see the videos on youtube.com
Anderson Cooper we are James Anderson
Cooper you'll see the videos maybe if
they come up what he means is where were
we at the DNC or was it this was a
number of times I talked to Anderson
Cooper a number one with Luke and
Anderson Cooper's walking around I was
like oh hey it looks Anderson Cooper and
then Luke runs up and goes why did you
intern at the CIA are you familiar with
project Mockingbird and he was like what
are you talking about yes first of all
but he was all friendly he was all
cheery talking to everyone I was like
hey I came off nice all right I didn't
come off that aggressive at first I
always kind of you know get there hi
Anderson how you doing and then you know
you got to get in there with some
serious questions I think it's important
your your example about in Poland and
communist countries you know I'm obvious
I'm a free speech Advocate I'm not an
advocate of tyranny I'm not an advocate
of Communism I'm gonna get nailed on
this later for being some sort of
communist totalitarian now but like I at
least understand the logic behind
suppress seeing speech that criticizes
the the state that's in power like that
makes sense to me it's like we want to
maintain our power over everybody so
yeah you can't say this it's a bad thing
but it is a bad thing but I understand
the logic there this I don't necessarily
understand we're talking about well this
is the slippery slope extreme minority
cases here I think the problem is I
didn't see what Steve did that got him
banned and he might have been insulting
people again like and if he does it over
and over hold on hold on hold on hold on
I look in the group when when like I or
I see somebody get made fun of over and
over and over and then they start crying
and then they feel like they can't be
themselves and they go home and they
want they hit themselves in the face
because they're so okay okay now now
let's talk about every single Trump
supporter who's been labeled a a slack
jawed Yokel who's been mocked and
belittled endlessly on me on mainstream
TV and then they just say white men are
not a minority group and I'm like I'm
literally talking about they're like the
viral uh there's a black woman who does
these really great videos where she just
rebuts all of these lies because there's
an Eclectic group of people who either
voted for Trump or conservative who are
just berated and insulted all day every
day and this is exactly what I said to
Jack Dorsey why are you singling out one
Community for special protection and not
any other exactly but but this is what I
was saying he said look when it comes to
the transgender Community there's a high
suicide rate so we're very you know
we're very partial to that and then I
said what about any other community with
high rates of suicide like like police
for instance my understanding military
military uh no they don't care now not
to be fair to be fair I'm pretty sure
they do have a rule against disparaging
veterans no joke I don't know exactly
how that works but I'm pretty sure they
don't enforce it the internet is built
off of insulting people you look at the
algorithms you look at Twitter you look
at Facebook what do they promote what do
they put on their timeline that's
carefully curated For You drama fighting
always at the top the I think it's a
part of a larger divide and conquer
agenda but if you're going to start uh
policing insulting people that's another
level of absurdity that there's no going
back from and and Jackie you can
understand the logic but understand this
is the beginning of a lot more bigger
problem problems don't attack me like
I'm supporting it dude I don't but but
I'm just trying to add another point to
what you're saying that it begins with
this kind of absurdity that you're
questioning I don't understand why
they're doing you're going to understand
it once it ratchets up and it comes to
the point where you go to jail for
expressing a thought and an idea someone
someone super chatted us just now they
said that Crowder did a skit about
California women's prisons handing out
condoms
oh my so so maybe maybe maybe that I
don't I don't know for sure that's part
of it but I don't know if he actually
did that I'm just saying someone's he's
like a bee that refuses to stop stinging
he does it on like Netflix behind the
scenes on a paywall yo Netflix has a
YouTube channel these clips are all
available on YouTube he doesn't Steve
goes on like every day and does this
stuff with a holster gun in his in his
pocket no he doesn't he's like all like
he's very like an oppressive force that
were true Ian they'd have given him a
strike on every single video he did not
unfortunately it's admins making
decisions at will it's not like a robot
I gotta sit here and listen to The
Psychotic ramblings of MSNBC Joy Reid
Rachel Maddow the hate speech the
insults the vile disgusting behavior and
you know what I get it I'm an adult yet
Crowder does one segment on a new story
and maybe he was doing a skit regardless
what about when when you get uh was it
Jimmy Kimmel doing blackface yeah yeah
do all of these things and and and I
think it's very very obvious what this
is if you are outside of the controlled
establishment narrative you are fair
game everyone else is fine I think you
made a good point that that going hard
on minorities is really cracked down I'm
going hard on people that they think our
majorities is fine
as soon as America becomes the uh White
minority nation that everyone is is
projecting do you think that they're
going to apply those same standards to
white people
depends on if they want to make
themselves
who are they there's people on the
mainstream media literally arguing that
you can't be racist to white people
because of the way that they were born
and that you could get away with
whatever you want to get away with
because they have privilege
exactly but that is allowed that is
promoted that is put in the algorithm
that is put in the rankings that is
showed to people far and wide with
unfair privileges to multinational
corporations that get the advantage over
Independent Media and still somehow
Independent Media is kicking their butts
still breathing for life and now they're
going to be nitpicking on what you can
and cannot say it's ridiculous if
they're going to go after Stephen
Crowder like this go take down the
Netflix YouTube channel for hosting Dave
Chappelle go take down Jimmy kimball go
take all of them down and then maybe you
could lecture us about what is
rightfully to do about abuse and
bullcrap out of here I'm sick of it and
it's and it's ridiculous I don't give a
damn what his name is he doesn't deserve
me to even pronounce his name right I'm
sick of them so I'm sick of him he's
really really doing a song and dancer
and that's Colbert but but they're
literally they're literally Shilling to
the point where they're spreading
dangerous fake news about people lining
up in the hospital not being able to get
help because of poison control
Ivermectin use when that's not true at
all exactly when after children these
all these opponents went after kids
might like these are minors fine yeah
the last point I want to make is like
education is so important and when I
mean education I mean the education
industry a lot of this stuff stems from
2011 dear colleague letter for Title IX
where they made it so that all
universities had to extinguish not just
abuse not just harassment but people
being made uncomfortable so now it's
been 10 years where these universities
are forced to do this or lose their
funding where they set up biased
response teams and secret hotlines to
report on fellow students that said
something that made you feel
uncomfortable and those kids get
sanctioned and there's no hearings and
there's no trials and there's no you
know representation there's no accusing
you know facing your accuser it's been
10 years of institutionalizing that type
of thought process and behavior and
people who are seniors then or 32 year
old now they're Executives at these
corporations and they're driving the
agenda because in 2011 they issued this
thing a deer called dear colleague
letter that changed college campuses and
now here we are seeing the fruits of
that 10 years later a free speech
depression I'll go on YouTube and type
bully fight sometimes or like Bully
Revenge because I always there's some
like fetish I have where I like seeing a
kid that's getting bullied like turn it
around and fight the bully and win yeah
that's always looking like good good for
that kid but now there's a thing pops up
and it says if you need the suicide
hotline call this number if you type if
you search for Bully revenge on YouTube
a hotline number that pops up that's new
we got we got more news in the
censorship field oh boy we got the story
from Daily Mail Instagram sensors
evolutionary biologist for posting a
chart from transgender study by
prominent science journal that showed
biological men are stronger than
biological women in a range of Olympic
sports
evolutionary biologist Colin Wright had
one of his Instagram posts removed for
hate speech and claims he was unable to
appeal his review now for those that
aren't familiar Collins actually been on
this show and he didn't post any hate
speech he posted science yep so he
basically was disparaging fauci that
explained wait wait no no no no no I'm
sorry Instagram is disparaging fauci
because fauci is science oh yeah right
yeah so that's how it works I'm told yes
okay there we go so so Instagram hates
science all right Colin Wright tweeted
Instagram took down one of my posts for
violating the rules on hate speech what
was the thing I posted a figure from
fond of Beatles and TL exercises
peer-reviewed paper showing male
advantage in certain Sports activity
they said avoid losing access to your
account in the future this shows the
chart so the chart was taken from a
study published in medicine and Sports
in sports and exercise which tested if
the international Olympic committee's
guidelines for transgender athletes
eliminated the performance Advantage
male athletes male athletes bodies give
them naturally and as we can see there
is absolutely according to the study a
male Advantage although I'm not here to
talk necessarily about the study just
the censorship this is this this is this
is it's crazy okay
they they claim all the science agrees
the experts agree and then they just
eliminate anybody from social media who
doesn't
so you've got these stories about
vaccine mandates and they're like 97 of
our Workforce is vaccinated yeah because
you fired you know the other how many
percentage of them so if you have if you
have a hundred people working at your
company and 60 of them get vaccinated
and then you fight and then you fire a
handful and you're like ah see let's say
only 40 we're not vaccinated so you're
60 40. then they fire the 40 people and
they say we're 100 vaccinated that's
what's happening they're they're they
they
I don't know
are we not allowed to talk about the
contents of that study probably not we
risk uh getting getting probably not but
we also we are because this is this is
insane look this is this that is truly
insane that you can't just say that a
dude is stronger than a woman well
that's a generalization not always
because some women are stronger than men
so but that's strong
that's post-modern well this is the
point we're talking about in general and
the science shows it there is a very
distinct difference if you're talking
about the extremes the the strongest
humans tend to be men tend to be are
exclusively it's not a hundred percent
every time it's every way all the time
you might have some aberrational human
that happens to be a female stronger
than the strongest the point is you
might you've not you've not actually
looked at the bell curve of research
data on this side I'm just saying it's
not that it can never happen that's the
point so when you look at uh grip
strength for instance oh here we go
we're gonna get videos made about this
oh absolutely people always do response
videos whenever we talk about
there's a scientific study we went over
on the show and look I'm gonna stress
this like this is not meant to be
disrespectful towards anybody we're just
trying to talk about science here and if
we if we get censored so be it uh the
strongest the the highest
um uh strength for grip strength among
women is around the average for a man
in the bell curve for uh jumping jumping
height distance jumping height and
distance the highest end of the bell
curve for men has no women anywhere near
it so so when it comes to the strongest
uh jumping strength or grip strength it
is exclusively like the top percentile
is male now there are some High bell
curve women as well who get very close
to the top but it is almost entirely I
mean you look at the basket look at the
NBA these guys are all what six seven
feet tall yeah that how many people on
the planet are seven feet tall it's not
that many and that means if there was a
there was a funny uh post I saw that
said if you're over seven feet tall you
have a 13 chance of being in the NBA no
no it's for real because even if you're
not that good the height advantages is
sought after for the NBA so this means
exclusively people I I will say it's not
exclusive Mugsy boes amazing yeah
showing you that strength and
perseverance and talent really does
matter a 42 inch vertical really helps
with that as well right it was amazing
he was amazing he was Spud Webb as well
too right yeah yeah so this is just part
of the whole trend of destroying
masculinity and destroying uh the idea
of what a man is and you just can't have
science saying that men are stronger so
we have to eliminate that and suppress
that I think histrologically men were
genetically we've just developed men to
developed the the snap strength power
because they had to run and hunt and and
they ran and hunted because they were
bigger and stronger bro and it's not
like playing basketball I think it comes
from the women staying home to protect
the child
we're both right yeah yes look it wasn't
like there were two completely
gender-neutral humans that once started
hunting and then became bigger or one of
them right and and one wasn't bigger
because it was hunting right natural
selection yes selected for those who are
expendable right there that's just
really cool there's this really like uh
one last thing on this there's this this
meme that's been going around in the
men's community and fitness Community
forever it's like there's an image of a
long distance Runner and an image of a
sprinter and and they people always use
that to be like this is why long
distance running is bad for you and this
is why you should do sprinting and
people people use that as a way to say
that like sprinting is going to make you
strong and powerful and and long
distance running is going to make you
weak and frail actually it's just that
those body types are the ones that are
most successful in those individual
sports the people who yeah there it is
the people who use that image to be like
sprinting makes you powerful are the
ones that are would also say that
playing basketball makes you tall it
just does it just is not logic guys I
would slightly disagree with you on your
point of course on your previous
statement uh when you said this is an
attack on males I think that this is an
attack on women because this
predominantly affects women and if you
look at what's been happening socially I
think masculine men have been
predominantly widely conquered already
and there still are a lot of outliers
when it comes to women standing up for
the family unit standing up for
femininity standing up for their true
kind of energetic power that they have
within themselves males I think have
that completely wiped out in certain
contexts but when you look at this
policy and this kind of larger culture
or shift I think this is a directed
targeted attack against femininity and
women and this is this is the the kind
of conflict that we're seeing unfold
right now I want to add to the grip
strength thing I actually saw another
really interesting study that said grip
strength correlating with uh how much uh
um with with uh with your heart with
heart strength and likelihood like a
heart attack or something okay yeah
apparently as as your heart weakens your
grip strength diminishes there's a
there's a vein here I think that goes
directly to your heart on your hand it's
part of why they put rings on that
finger there's like a vein you know what
I have this crazy theory that all of
your veins are connected to your heart
no way dude that's a crazy Theory
imagine your intelligence
sorry I want to point out about if you
had an agent if you had an ancient tribe
of 20 men and 20 women and then five of
the men died you're still going to be
able to produce 20 children we've talked
about this uh in Fallout uh The Fallout
story uh you're familiar with Fallen I
imagine right the video game series
there's uh for those those are not
familiar no this is this is good because
people will have basically there's a
fiction where humans have written about
these ideas uh fallout post-apocalyptic
Wasteland the government builds a bunch
of underground bunkers called vaults one
of the vaults was called Vault 69 where
it was I think it was 99 women and one
man
and then there was another Vault called
I think it was Vault 68 where it was 99
men and one woman that's not gonna work
and so so at the end of the day there
was one man left they write about this
because uh
you know the idea is if you have a
hundred men and 100 women and 99 men die
your civilization is fine I mean it's
hard it's it's it's it's your culture
your tribe whatever is hurt but it will
survive because you can have 99 babies
in nine months and you basically the
point of this is yeah maybe nine months
in a week men are genetically like more
disposable they built up
right exactly like bodies that could
handle like trauma in short term and
they would go and do dangerous things
and get killed off but it was okay
because as long as you still had those
20 women you could produce 20 children
per year five of the women died you can
only produce 15 children per year and
that's that's why you need to have big
strong scary men to defend the women
from big strong scary things
came from yes this is this is it's very
very uh utilitarian it's just men Were
Expendable and uh it's nature selection
for the men who are more likely to
survive and the men are more likely to
survive we're stronger world now where
we don't have to fight Bears anymore so
it's like I think the Consciousness is
Shifting and people are starting to
think of it differently still we're
still genetically from what we were we
still have to fight Bears uh we just had
a bear attack here but we have guns now
right
um what we have done is dramatically
reduce the threat to to the need for
muscle
and so now what's happening I think it's
a natural consequence of this is that
nature is now selecting uh outside of
the parameters of expendability or
strength now how does that happen women
are the ones that select
women are the ones that select for
strength and power and perhaps the issue
was the reason why these men didn't
procreate was because they were weaker
and they would die when they tried to
fight a wolf or a bear yeah and the
stronger men survived and had the kids
right now it perhaps women make
selections based on a large variety of
factors which doesn't include pure
strength kill the bear come back to the
Village
get all the brides now it's there's no
real bear fight for most people in
cities so it's but psychologically there
is right so go to a bar get drunk have
kids yeah
psychologically though there is still
the need there is still the need to be a
protector right and I think that that's
that's the more meta element of this is
is protect and provide versus nurture
and care and I don't know that those
elements are gone right people like
women seem to enjoy this is a very big
generation guys that can fix things now
like fix broken pipes I hear a lot like
I want a man that can go out there with
a chainsaw and cut down a tree but you
do need muscle for that it helps that be
really strong you can carry branches and
break things that are the more the more
that we automate hard labor the more the
more weaker men will survive to to but
those are weaker weaker in in
physicality but you still have to be
stronger mentally and you still have to
protect and provide so it's a slightly
modified but protect and provide is
still a thing but it's more about
getting money being funny now is a thing
like it's different it's very simple
protecting and providing is very
different so you take a look at what's
going on with male feminists what does
protect mean they're gonna defend the
woman and all of her political opinions
right and so they become male feminists
and then provide what does that mean
they're going to go work any job where
they can stand I can't really get paid
and those are the biggest creepers and
predators out there according to some
statistics According to some people's
personal opinions but also dating apps
have had a huge effect on a lot of the
kind of social interactions we have
where the top one percent of males bag a
lot of the women and the okay guy and
the average guy are left uh holding the
bag with not many options for themselves
when women get hit up uh no matter what
kind of scale there are on the 0 to 10
scale uh they get thousands of messages
no matter what so that also has a huge
effect on socially what's happening
right now and uh overall there's been
less marriages less relationships less
people making kids in the western world
and I think those consequences and those
effects especially when you look at
what's happening in China when they're
trying to prioritize masculine men
they're trying to prioritize families
they're trying to prioritize uh
nationalism
this is a completely different approach
and throughout the generations we're
going to see the consequences of those
two different approaches and it's not
going to be good for the United States
this is really interesting because I
wonder you know we talk about the fall
of of ancient Rome and I'm wondering if
something happens with I guess you would
call it behavioral sync where if a
society becomes well protected well-fed
well established but can only grow so
fast within the confines of that does it
really to be does it lead to behavioral
sync
a female mate selection definitely has
an impact on the overall you know sort
of uh statistical distribution of male
attributes and strength and power and
all these things and uh I you know dude
I I'm very sympathetic to this argument
about dating apps uh as as a tall
handsome smart successful guy I
certainly saw the other side of that
don't criticize yourself that way
so don't be that modest but but I will I
will point out though that those Trends
were actually in place long before the
uh apps came along the declining
fertility rate Decline and marriage
rates increase in marriage age Etc were
well in place before those apps came
about it has exacerbated it and of
course it's someone we're here we're
talking about the way Twitter and
YouTube and algorithms change and shape
the dialogue and our politics and how
what we think about each other of course
the same kind of algorithms are at work
in these dating apps and are affecting
the mating dating and mating markets and
frankly it was my analysis and
exploration into that phenomenon which
has gotten me to where I am now 10 years
later after my divorce in 2009 pulling
on the same threads trying to figure
this stuff out and here we are talking
about these big meta issues safety is in
my opinion the number one issue that is
driving a lot of those of those things
getting married later on you know so so
so you mentioned protecting and
providing is like a masculine role
versus what was the other one nurturing
caring nurturing and caring is like the
more feminine role and it used to be
back in the day that you had a parent to
watch the kids times change for a
variety of reasons but ultimately I
think it has to do with the sphere of
safety that we've created and you can
take a look at how that manifests now in
the modern era with safe spaces with
censorship with offense culture and
victim culture we have become so
incredibly safe that people have become
soft wads of cookie dough that are
terrified and victimized by stubbing
their toe I remember in this this sorry
just ultimately this this selects for
the the biological success of historical
people who historically would not likely
be people yeah in school I mean think of
elementary school on the playground
girls and boys playing this is like my
personal experience I remember seeing
this stuff a boy would make fun of
another boy and start talking him down
and saying you're terrible you're blah
and then other boys will start to laugh
and stand around and then the girls
would flock to the kid that was making
fun of the other kid as if he was
becoming the protector of the the whole
the herd and they're like this guy
because of through his mean hierarchy or
whatever he's doing is now creating a
safe place for me to raise like he's
going to protect us from he's going to
demean others to grow his strength and
that's like deeply ingrained in what I
am I I think that's just part of the
hierarchy of being animal and now
they're trying to algorize that out and
say allergize that's a new one for me
look there's look there's two things
happening here one most men I believe it
might be most or at least close to a
majority of men over time have not
reproduced and socially enforced
monogamy is a way to solve for that
problem then add in no fault divorce and
discouraging women from you know seeking
out men who are protectors and providers
and becoming protectors and providers
themselves is exacerbating this problem
but it's also given us this contrast
where we've moved out of the social
socially enforced monogamy into back the
wild west the state of nature when it
comes to mating and of course not all
guys are going to reproduce at this
point there's going to be a lot of guys
left out socially enforced monogamy was
a way to bring men into society to give
them a reason to live a reason to build
and create well that's interesting so uh
I think you're right and I think if we
combine these ideas basically there was
a period where you typically wouldn't
see you know weaker men as successful as
as you would say I mean physically right
and and in fact in many instances
mentally because life was a lot harder
and people didn't survive conflict and
if you couldn't make it but now these
people are doing well really well but
you make a good point they're also
struggling on dating apps the the age of
a male who is a virgin is getting higher
and higher meaning I think the last data
was a few years ago Washington Post
released a study that men under 30 were
like a third of them were virgins and so
what we're seeing now with dating apps
is that is typically a small handful of
men getting all of the women which is
like a reversion back to the state of
nature of Nature and I think resources
don't matter as much as they did before
especially in this ever-changing
landscape that is more influenced by
social media and Hollywood and I think a
perfect representation of that is uh Mr
Bill Gates if you look at Mr Bill Gates
there's stories and accusations of him
having a very hard time getting women at
his own company so if you're talking
about one of the richest people in the
world at the time even having that kind
of trouble uh you know going off hanging
and partying with Epstein but that's
another story there but but but a man
with all the resources is having a hard
time even even getting a girlfriend at
Microsoft so sure there's a bunch of
Microsoft jokes we can make here
I I'm above that uh I'm above that uh
not really but at the rest stop
but but it is it is an ever-changing
economy that is very interesting that I
think is still changing and it's very
hard to kind of classify even what's
going on we are in a crazy state of
change we are between two fixed points
we are in what we call a liminal period
right we had a very fixed circumstance
you had culturally enforcement monogamy
no fault divorce everybody gets married
everybody has a couple kids everybody
works that has dissipated we're now back
into a new sort of explosion we don't
know or implosion and we don't know
where it's going to settle it's not
looking good for the average guy and
what happens when the average guy
is disgruntled and then there's a lot of
them and I think China is facing that
facing look you know looking down the
barrel at that you know traditionally
what do you do with your Surplus men you
send them off to war right and they have
a lot of surplus men in China they have
a huge uh population disparity where
literally
you caught that whatever yeah you know
what I'm saying yesterday you know what
I'm saying
good thing we're not on TV I speak
multiple languages okay English was not
my first language it doesn't matter oh I
got it okay now you're making fun of a
minority yeah I'm a person of color
according to person Google exactly
exactly so you better watch out Jack
um there's men literally competing for
women on the streets in in some cities
in China trying to get one date with one
girl and they have entire competitions
where their entire town comes out to see
which man will get to date this single
woman so on that kind of level well this
is all because of the kind of eugenics
population control agenda that
Rockefeller and Ted Turner pushed and
promoted with China that made them have
one child policy that prioritized
specifically males being born and a lot
of baby girls were either aborted or
terminated or smuggled out of the
country because culturally uh in in
China the male takes care of the family
and if you have a female and if you're
only allowed one child you're not going
to have someone that will take care of
you so that made a huge I mean the
Rockefeller policy on China the one
child policy was absolutely uh you know
horrible to say when you combine that
effect in China with in their history of
like sending men to war with like spoons
butter knives and sticks up against guys
with machine guns they're doing that in
Pakistan that's what I'm saying dude the
Chinese I think I might be wrong on this
but in the Korean War I do believe
they've stormed over the border with
nothing but like sticks and spoons and
butter knives and they went to Valley
and battle like that they are willing to
do whatever they they can and if you're
going to have Surplus men in an
imperialist environment with aspirations
for growth and dominance I mean that's a
that's an interesting situation for
Taiwan well for first during a week
presidency that literally does the
opposite of what he's supposed to do
during military conflict like he did in
Afghanistan so so are we looking at
you know we talk about the city's trap
we talk about just China's as a growing
military power but it's the real reason
War breaks out is because China looks at
the USS we got too many dudes if we're
stuck that are frustrated Thunderdome if
we're stuck well it's not too many it's
just like hey look what do we have to
work with here oh look at that we got
all these dudes what could we do with
them they're useful space travel that's
the thing if we're stuck in uh this is
why he is on the show this is why
behavioral sing and this is the reason
behavioral sync went the way it did is
because they couldn't spread out they
were stuck in an enclosed space like we
are on earth and if we keep growing like
we're growing and we're still stuck here
either these people that want to reduce
the population growth or War I think are
the two inevitable um people who've been
making this space travel I don't know
Mars yeah although now Imperials to do
that right you just like a slingshot
from down here you can get a magnetic
slingshot and then another reverse
magnetic slingshot in the Martian orbit
so they kept it slows it down and
catches it and then sends it down on an
elevator with a graphene tether to uh
the outer rim comes and destroys it I've
been watching that show on Apple I read
the books what if the policy was in
instead of the one child policy it was
the one child two a second one child
second astronaut policy so after your
first time tomorrow the second kid was
was going to go in the astronaut program
and we're like we got a kid send him to
Mars colonizing dude they raised in
space you send your second kid up into
orbit to have them be raised up you're
gonna spend like a hundred million
dollars to send somebody into space you
don't want it to be like the knucklehead
of your family that didn't have any
that's the problem is it's too expensive
that's why the space elevator is
fascinating yeah but too expensive it's
rocketry there's two ways you can look
at it quantity or quality and quality
would be like let's get 10 great
astronauts and send them up there to
build this or you can be like or a
hundred dumb ones and like if each of
them only does 10 output you know they
won't if they make it a week they make
it but you know you send enough of them
up there and they're going to colonize
by the way I am never going into space
what about orbit I might do what uh
Shatner just did yeah but I'm definitely
not going to Mars I'm definitely not
going out there and being trapped in a
tin can in the middle of a cold dark
with the current no uh with the current
setup like with the current um
environment right if it was like Tom
Swift style where it was like a rotating
cylinder like Elysium right where it's
like this amazing Earth-like atmosphere
with like millions of plants and lakes
and stuff maybe that you Diva
what about on a spaceship in orbit just
to float for a while no no hold on there
a minute hold on comfy bed for that let
me ask you something though so uh the
colonists who are who are leaving the
comfort of their of their countries
where they had you know a system in
place and economy said I'm gonna get on
this boat it's going to take me three
months to maybe get to a place I've
never seen before but people tell me it
sounds good A lot of people are gonna
die on the boat from various illnesses
diseases scurvy is going to affect them
really bad and then if they make it
they're landing on the shore where
there's nothing right Barren land and
they were like yo sounds good right well
hey how bad was life B that's but that's
like the the promise of a potential
paradise and don't forget that many of
the people that made that Journey were
looking for a new Zion they were
American zionists looking to create
God's Paradise on Earth and they weren't
going to do it in established civilized
Europe they had to go do it in the
wilderness of North America now look
dude if you're trying to tell me that
like I understand that the process of
being in a spaceship going to Mars
terrible the process of being on a boat
sailing to the new world also terrible
landing on Mars terrible Landing in the
new world ah Paradise everything you
want what was Paradise about it there
were animals and trees and lakes and
rivers and resources and food I mean I
know they didn't figure it out right
away but there's plenty of food and game
and all these things and a huge expanse
uh yeah no space Red Dust voids vacuums
they're they're I think they're just
people that uh got the Explorer bug
totes I think I think there's still a
lot on the on the planet we need to
explore well a lot of people were facing
religious uh persecution yeah and and
that's why a lot of them left you under
you got to understand you're all the
Trump supporters
exactly Mars yeah there was plagues
there was diseases there was war there
was there was there was lack of food so
anything other than that was was was
better for a lot of people that's why
they took the risk of going overseas and
think about it too once it was
established here why do people immigrate
to the United States
because it's better immigrating to Mars
is worse this is what bugs me
have you been to Mars let me tell you I
saw I saw that uh total when I when I
was like 18.
listen when I was like 18 we had hard
Winters in Chicago so you can't skate
very much in the winter it sucks that
means everybody knows like you get rusty
you get tired you get out of shape and
so we knew some people who had a private
Warehouse with a mini ramp and a skate
on and I was like guys we need to do
this too we need to have our own indoor
space if we all pitch in a hundred bucks
right now we got it the original
communist you know what they uh it all
said to me do it and then once you have
it I'll think about joining and I said
the only way we get it is if we work
together right now to do it and they
said and then they did nothing all
winter and sat around just getting fat
and lazy I can't I can't I can't stand
that yo if you if you want to find a new
place or a new world I'm saying I'm not
saying it's you I'm saying for the
people who do you couldn't go to Mars
and put in the work don't expect someone
else's with immigration yeah they all
want to come here now because a bunch of
people risked life and limb to cross an
ocean many I think it was like 20 people
on boats died they finally get here and
there was conflict and there was Crisis
and there was some bad BS that went down
a lot of it mind you and then they built
a civilization and now it's so beautiful
everybody's like I want to go there and
I'm gonna and screw their laws screw
their rules I'm gonna go take whatever I
want now do the work put in the work
earn your keep help keep the system that
you want so badly to keep functioning
Tim uh universal healthcare right here
earn your key I'm I'm absolutely this is
this is this is the thing I I'm totally
for Universal Health Care but not the
way Bernie Sanders wants to do it yeah
and the other problem is you get a
government that has control over your
health care and then all of a sudden
they're they're doing vaccines by race
right which is what they tried doing
right so anyway I digress yeah people
should be explorers maybe Pioneers we
can resettle the American Interior there
is so much to do there there's so many
places let's go settle Alaska yes and I
think at this point it's not only cool
but like inevitably necessary if we want
to avoid war to expand into space I know
it seems like a daunting task to
terraform Mars but we can do it we could
terraform we could add set up
civilizations on the moon you know there
are ways if you if you really take time
out of the equation we have to send
massive cargo payloads
so just over over the span of several
years so that we finally send the first
team they show up with like 20 years
worth of food and fuel and and building
materials and then they can build
biospheres and domes and stuff like that
but ultimately I'm not I'm not convinced
Mars colonization is a real thing I
don't think so either by the time by the
time we can terraform Mars we could just
fix any climate issues here terraform
yeah we'll be terraforming Mars has no
magnetosphere it has a weak one so it
means I can't use my compass sorry it
looks like this it means you'll get
bombarded by radiation and solar
particles and then you'll just enjoy it
again this is why no one has gone past
the Van Allen the van what is it Van
Allen belt the Van Halen no I don't
think that's true because we went to the
moon did we though just kidding are we
allowed to say that maybe I don't know
about that crap I'm just kidding
Stanley Kubrick didn't make art about it
as well but apparently we did go to the
Moon too yeah but why haven't we been
back dog I think it's just expensive
he's not getting anything out of it yeah
this one's always crazy to me it's like
how do we get to the moon dude we
literally built a rocket we had tons of
rockets Rockets are not hard and then
you just do basic math for like how to
get there why haven't we gone back
because we didn't get anything from
doing it other than wagging our finger
at Russians we don't have them no
there's a lot of military capabilities
on being on the moon sure sure and
China's looking at going back on the
moon to launch uh military installations
there so I'm with Jack on this one I
agree oh my God I can't believe this is
happening high five we actually agreed
on something probably underground you'll
want to colonize on the moon yeah so you
can avoid that like make it a death star
a vacuum like build a gigantic ion you
know Canon or laser beam it looks like
the crater it looks like a small Moon it
looked like Mars was ripped open at some
point there's a big scar and that a
bunch of its core came out onto the
surface and then all that iron core came
down as iron oxide dust so you have all
that red dust and that's why the
magnetosphere has been weakened because
it's missing a lot of that iron that was
in the middle so we've either
reintroduced the iron into the core or
try and I don't know you know what this
we can nuke the cores and jump start
them you know what they say about real
estate location locations sounds like a
terrible the people that came to the US
first are the now the the great
ancestors of the landowners and all
these rich people they right right so so
actually I think this is the look we can
talk all day about iron oxide and cores
and all that stuff but I think the real
issue that I wanted to bring up is is
that is that Pioneer Spirit still within
our hearts yeah I think I think it is
and do you find it in the
entrepreneurial spirit in the United
States but people building and creating
and inventing and exploring new
technological Frontiers they did that in
London you know they had a big city that
universities they had science and math
and Industry Bezos and musker a good
example of no but where where are the
people uh James Cameron James Cameron
with the submarine and all that that's
what I'm talking about building cities
yeah like all we
all week Hey where's anyone to be like I
have just bought land and I have staked
my claim and now I think there's a I
think that I think that happens more and
more than in Texas yeah you guys see
that that company that wants to do the
weird city of like leftists Utopia
whatever no I haven't we got we got how
are you going to criticize the lack of
the pioneer Spirit and the first example
someone gives you you're like those
weirdos
all the work people want to go into
their own private City like yeah it's
fantastic yeah they have it it's called
Washington DC we just sealed the deal on
on for domican oh there you go we
officially got it and we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna put up our little
street names and we're gonna start
building stuff out and just you know we
want to get an FFL Luke's adamant about
you know a thousand yard range we're not
going to do that come on we can but I
think we shouldn't it's extremely
difficult considering like we're not in
the middle of nowhere nowhere it's a big
property but if we're going to be
setting up freedomastan meaning we gotta
have a lot of facilities and buildings
then I don't think we can allocate you
know nothing nothing's impossible it
looks like the Chinese are building time
and money yeah we'll figure it out
building Islands well I'll tell you this
colonization is happening and it's China
and it's and it's happening for a lot of
the same reasons it's overcrowded people
want to find a better place to live so a
lot of Chinese citizens are are going
out to other countries and setting up
and expanding so I I I I think we were
talking about this with Africa South
America code we've talked about it quite
a bit it's not like a militaristic uh
operation it's just literally someone in
China being like it's crowded I want
work hey here's an opportunity there's a
company that's hiring in this country
that's Building Bridges or or selling
oil or something so they move out there
with their families and then you end up
getting these pockets of Chinese
Nationals living in all these different
places
where people aren't trying sorry people
aren't doing that I remember being here
in Kenya Zimbabwe and Somalia and I was
astonished at how many Chinese people I
saw all over the place running around
there and I had a lot of local Africans
being like this is this is the new wave
of imperialism they are the new
colonizers the Chinese have come in and
they're taking over uh resources they're
taking over infrastructure and they're
also building a lot of infrastructure
there so ports and harbors all over the
place by the way some of the best
Chinese food I ever had was in Ecuador
what do you know but what kind of
Chinese food was it Sichuan it was like
it was like real like you know like
diced chicken with rice or whatever I've
never been to China except for Hong Kong
so I can't really tell you but it was
pretty good I I got a funny life lesson
for people you know what uh I went to
Thailand
and I'm with uh this guy I was working
with Vice and I was like I want to eat
real Thai food and he was like oh you
want to eat real Thai food right and I
was like yeah yeah real stuff none of
that Americanized heavily sugared and
fat stuff he's like you want to eat like
the real Thai people like yes he said
come with me and we go down to this
little uh there's like a little like
corner of a building on a block like a
residential area and they've got these
big shutters that have been open and
there's a little kitchen looks like a
regular old kitchen and I walk in and he
orders in Thai and you know what they
come out with
steamed chicken and rice yeah that's it
literally just steamed chicken and rice
and I started laughing and he's like
what do you think people eat like
Americans are so spoiled everything's
got sugar fat salt spices regular people
around the world they're eating rice and
meat dude
in in South America there's a saying
that they have rice and beans for lunch
and beans and rice for dinner I noticed
that when I was down there yeah I went
to Brazil and I said the same thing to
uh to my Brazilian friend I was like I'm
gonna eat like a real Brazilian and he's
like all right and we went and it was
just well it was just steak they give
you they give you like two steaks and
then everyone sits around it and you cut
them and you take it with rice but there
is one thing they do they sprinkle
cornmeal on top oh that was different I
think you're what you're also arguing is
just how what a wonderful Bounty of
authentic food that we have here in the
United States Thai food is it's like
yeah it's very I mean dude you can get
uh papaya salad in Thailand on the
street which is one of my favorites I
love Sticky Rice on the street yeah well
and then you can you just get it right
here in the United States too I was in
Thailand too man I ate street food all
the time but what I mean is like these
like these like specialty meals that we
think of they're like oh yeah like faux
like a like yeah when you go to these
countries for the most part regular food
is just regular food it's not you know
it's not some fancy like I was like I
want pad thai and he was like okay you
know it's kind of well what's regular
American food dude uh meatloaf and
mashed potatoes yeah Burgers instant
mashed potatoes instant mashed potatoes
I think I think peas and steak with
mashed potato peas in a steak or
something murder Burger I don't know
anybody who eats peas really that was my
favorite food how many peas they sell
them at stores
I care not for the peas oh they're a
little sweet cancel me now it's good for
babies do you guys remember that New
York Times article where they said mixed
peas into your guacamole and then there
was like a Revolt where the left and the
right came together like with that fist
meme like no I try it it sounds terrible
murder are you a vegan hell no oh well
that's crazy I don't understand what you
meant by the murder Burger okay the
Mickey D's oh yeah well I don't even
know what we're talking about anymore
basically Pakistan Pakistan is up on the
map up there yeah
you mentioned China sending in their men
to go fight with sticks and stones that
they literally did that they did that
yeah
um can we talk about Kyrie Irving a
little bit is that is
shut up and dribble they say well I
don't know if you want to bring it up to
him but what about Kyrie some say that
well he just came out and made a
statement saying that he's not against
the vaccine he's against the mandates
and that he also wants to be a voice for
the voiceless and that he's making a a
uh you know that's what he said exactly
but what he's doing is he's making a
stand on this issue there's also a 26
year old Atlanta Hawks basketball player
named Brandon Goodwin who's reporting
that that according to his own personal
experiences it was the vaccine that
ruined his MBA career and he's saying
that he got a blood clots uh fatigue
respiratory conditions he got sick after
the the vaccine and he's blaming it on
ending it his ending it his uh
basketball career his professional
sports career well look look we don't
know if that's true but
this guy claiming he had this experience
clearly it's a dangerous conspiracy
theory you know he's just he his his
theory about these things happening to
himself certainly are are not correct uh
anecdotal at best so he apparently we
have the story um I just Googled it I
don't know what this source is it just
says former Atlanta Hawks guard Brandon
Goodwin claims covid-19 vaccine ended
his season Goodwin left nothing up to
the imagination to his twitch audience
recently this is from uh just about a
week and a half ago oh the only thing I
can really say is yo like vares exists
for a reason the vaccine adverse event
Reporting System exists for a reason and
I just wanna I wanna stress this point
yeah maybe he's telling the truth but if
you're vaccinating 330 million people
and there's Adverse Events of being
possible then you're going to get these
stories we got to be careful not to take
volume and and and compare it with like
uh proportionality but I don't know I
don't know I'm not gonna pretend to be I
can only say this I agree the vaccine
mandates are wrong and if you're getting
stories like this and people are
freaking out people got to be told to go
to people they know and trust and be
able to make decisions they for
themselves and if people want to assume
risks in their life that's their choice
for me I don't smoke I hate smoke I
can't stand people smoking around me
if I go to a bar and people are smoking
I expect I'll go outside I'll go
somewhere else I'm not going to be like
everyone here should
well there's definitely an interesting
debate happening right now because you
have a lot of sports commentators
attacking Kyrie uh saying that he's you
know an idiot a loser that he's stupid
for doing this uh but there's also you
know the the tale of of Magic Johnson
who had HIV and there was a big
discussion about even allowing him to
play uh in the NBA and there was people
saying he shouldn't play he's at risk to
other players we should ban him he
shouldn't have the right to play in the
NBA now I feel like people are making
that argument especially with this claim
with the you know you know with Kyrie
Irving who's being denied uh the access
to even play sports because of you know
something that some medical
professionals uh estimate that there is
low risk when it comes to professional
athletes from even getting
um and and there's also the debate of
you know if all the other players are
are vaccinated well then uh you know
wouldn't it work why do we need to have
him do it as well so that's the
conversation that's happening online
right now and I I think it's a very
interesting one because it's going back
and forth a Trader you know stupid guy
and people are saying he's doing the
right thing making a stand here for
people who don't have a voice so I think
it's I think it's a good decision I
support his decision to make his own
personal decision right and people are
talking about the money that he's giving
up but you know it's useful to consider
the money that he's already made right
he's in a position of comfort because of
the work and energy and effort that he's
put in and I don't begrudge him that
whatsoever but he does have the luxury
of having this type of conscience that
most Americans do not have and uh so
that is the kind of person who could
actually take a risk and make a make a
statement and actually make something
positive happen whereas you know just a
regular guy with a regular job and
regular family if he doesn't do it and
he gets fired that's not going to have
political change he's in position to do
that so I I pulled up Brandon Goodwin
Wikipedia it says Goodwin missed the
2021 NBA playoffs due to a respiratory
condition oh yeah so uh you know there
are other NBA players speaking out
against this
um whether you like them or dislike them
I know some people have different mixed
feelings about Kyrie Irving at least
there's a conversation uh at least
there's a discussion here that wouldn't
have happened I think people are trying
to dismiss this conversation but I think
being open to this conversation to
people's concerns is something that will
help everyone out in the long run and I
think that's why it's so imperative to
to talk through these issues the irony
here sorry Shannon sharp I think was
talking very loudly about how Kyrie
Irving should just basically shut up and
play but at the same time uh back in May
of last year when people were protesting
because of George Floyd you had people
also saying shut up and play and so uh
there were people criticizing those who
said that then who are now saying shut
up and play now it's very interesting
how this issue is actually Crossing
party lines it is a bit different I mean
the issue here is like Kyrie Irving
can't play there is no shut up and play
it's him literally being like hey guys I
can't play because of this well sure but
the shut up part is take the shot it was
uh right uh but there's there's a
difference LeBron could have just played
the game but he wanted to be political
yeah so I think it was Laura Ingram who
said Shut Up and dribble is that she was
the one who said it well it was Shannon
sharp I was talking about making this
comparison and telling Kyrie Irving to
just get the shot and go play people are
depending on your teammates are
depending on yourself he's not a mule
kayak you can do whatever you want
you're the reason the Cavs won the first
championship just kidding it was a team
game
bro and if you're gonna have some time
off so first the team said he can't play
home games if he doesn't get vaccinated
and now they say he can't participate at
all with the team so if you've got time
on your hands bro come on here and you
know what's funny is like when LA County
came out with their vax mandate I didn't
look into the details but one could
assume that performers were excluded
right so I was thinking like you
couldn't go to a Lakers game if you
didn't have a vaccine but are they going
to require all the incoming players to
get the vaccine of course not because
Prof formers politicians Etc they all
have exemptions from these vaccines well
not with not not in New York City not
with Kyrie Irving
um and and it's really interesting in
New York City even the performers are
required to be back players are the
players are yeah we're kind of
Performing you know it's a type of
performance yeah it's it's very weird uh
that this is happening a lot of people
are saying that Kyrie should be traded
to a team in Florida uh so there's a lot
of discussions about that but there's
also a lot of people just kind of taking
cheap shots at them and even though I
don't kind of agree with his other
previous political positions
um you know it's okay and I I think his
stand here is definitely worth noting
because a lot of people in the
mainstream media a lot of people try to
dismiss it try to act like there's this
point of view that doesn't exist it
clearly does it's here and and I think
ignoring it only makes it grow but by
addressing it you you could actually do
the right thing here uh and actually be
able to uh you know talk things out in a
way where it leads to less harm more
understanding and it fixes a lot of the
problems that we have in our current
Society so I believe there are other NBA
players who have come out so that
they're not vaccinated because they have
the antibodies Bradley Beal I think in
Washington was one of them as well uh
more people need to speak up man the
antibodies from having the infection are
something that we really need to address
yeah I just I disagree we talked about
this quite a bit oh it changes the
argument from no mandates to mandates
with exceptions I see so when you know
when Rand Paul comes out and he's like
natural antibodies are being you know
lied about and fouchy lied I'm like why
are you even discussing it who cares you
shouldn't be demanding people's papers
indeed indeed I agree with that 100 but
like is it better to uh just deal with
the vax Mandate in 100 capacity uh or
have your binary position or at least
also try to chip away at the binary
if we are standing on the line shocked
if we're standing in line and the line
is do you accept the mandates or not I
say no and you won't get me to cross
that line and apparently a lot of
Southwest Pilots feel the same way but
it's also it's worth mentioning that a
vaccine against us is different than
testing to not have it in your system
because there have been evidence that
people that get the vaccine can still
get coveted evidence there's that just
came out Harvard study that showed that
the vaccine correlated with increased
rates of transmission
Harvard I I'm not considering another
stuff proof I get this news and data and
this and that it's evidence to me but
there is evidence yeah
um I tweeted it today I find it yeah
there's there's a lot of medical studies
and and you know it's also important to
note here just like you know some
doctors that we talked about earlier
were censored on Instagram it's also
important to note that there are medical
professionals there are doctors there
are studies that if you do talk about on
social media that they do take away your
channel they do take down videos a lot
of doctors a lot of prominent medical
professionals have had their accounts
terminated so there is this aspect of
this as well but there's you know actual
science which should be debated which
should be questioned that it's being
denied to a lot of people and you know a
lot of people say the science is settled
well the science seems to be changing a
lot I tweeted a video today on my
Twitter account on at Luke we are change
and it's a music video and it's Dr fauci
saying 100 safe and effective 100 safe
and effective and then you have all the
media reports 100 regurgitating the same
thing and then it goes to 99 98 97 96
literally all the way down to some media
Publications reporting 33 percent
um effective so there's different media
airports there's a lot of noise there's
a lot of distractions out there but you
know we have to understand here we're in
a very fast moving situation uh that we
still don't know the full long-term
ramifications of I'm gonna I gotta
disagree
it's it looks like an op-ed Based on
data not a Harvard study made a
conclusion okay but I don't know for
sure I don't know for sure I found that
with a lot of these studies there's
Harvard data but I don't see a study
other than just data charts you know
breaking down from my experience there
are some studies that are are risky to
bring up but if you bring them up and
have it's in the paper the link there's
a link is in the first sentence if you
have legit debate like we can do on the
show if it's you in a room it's hard to
like break through the Echo and you
might you might frame it in a way that's
dangerous but if you let me have a
Collegiate debate yeah I'm gonna read
this headline it says increases in
covid-19 are unrelated to levels of
vaccination across 68 countries and 2
947 countries counties in the United
States I think if you dig in there
according to the article that I linked
to you man I'm on the spot I'm having to
restart re-examine it it's also
important to note that we are not
medical professionals we are not medical
doctors yeah but I don't know I'm like
if there's if there's a Harvard study
saying that there's a correlation I
think it's the opposite actually Jack
this this study that was linked to it
says increasing code are unrelated to
levels of vaccination now that that is
that that specifically literally means
vaccines aren't causing or anyway
related to an increase but it does show
that the increase is unrelated to
vaccination which is strange because
there should be a decrease so there's
also some interesting preliminary data
when you look at case cases in Singapore
Iceland Israel and the United Kingdom
some of the places that had the highest
vaccination rates and when you look at
their case numbers there's a there's
there's a correlation there that is not
an easy one to talk about and we have to
tread lightly here because again uh you
know correlation does not prove
causation but but there is something
going on here that I think we don't
fully understand the quote from the
research says in fact the trend line
suggests a marginally positive
Association such that countries with
higher percentage of population fully
vaccinated have higher covid-19 cases
per 1 million people so one thing that
makes me think is that not that the
vaccine is causing the body to make it
happen more but that people are more
confident because they've been
vaccinated so they're going to public
places
factors the symptoms are reduced the
symptoms are your first sign that you're
sick and should self quarantine if you
don't have symptoms then you can go out
well it depends because there's also
some places reporting that most of the
people hospitalized are the people who
did go through the procedure so there's
ours again there are some preliminary
reports uh you guys got to do your own
research you got to talk to your medical
professionals you got to make up your
own mind we're not telling you guys what
to do here uh we're not the medical
professionals we're not the medical
doctors but there is a lot of outlining
data out there that we have to kind of
talk about in a roundabout way because
it's a landmine sometimes and it's
important not to jump to conclusions
it's important not to just you know go
with one thing and say this is 100 the
truth because honestly I don't think a
lot of people know exactly what's
happening here uh and to say you're
definitively understanding this I think
is disingenuous the least I say we talk
about
Superman being gay bisexual too that's a
safer conversation you know the economy
going down uh you know energy Superman
because you were you were talking a lot
about masculinity and I think you're
saying the attack on masculinity and so
we actually have the story from NPR
Superman's son comes out as bisexual in
a new comic it's a big deal sort of now
first I will just say in no uncertain
terms
I don't I don't care to be completely
honest I I saw this and I was like huh
like it doesn't affect my life I'm not
going to buy the comic I don't care if
someone made the comic if you like the
comic that's all the by all means and I
hope you enjoy it but I will tell you it
was really funny I tweeted so there was
a you know a tweet about this and I
tweeted Superman is gay like as just
like a point of observation that was a
great sweep but I'm like it it didn't
mean anything I'm just like I'm like oh
yeah look at that Superman is gay and
because he's kissing a guy and and and
the left got mad at me and I was like
well hold on what did I say that was
offensive like it's literally a picture
of Superman kissing a dude he's bisexual
yeah I get that and let me be but you
know like I guess is that what but
that's not why they were mad bisexual's
not gay that's probably why they were
mad because they never did gay as
meaning bad right they didn't tweet at
me Tim you're wrong he's bisexual some
did the people who are mad they were
like they were posting memes as if I was
complaining about it as if I was angry
about it yes the perception of text man
there's very little why did they
perceive me just pointing out he's
kissing a guy and saying he's gay why do
they perceive that as an attack it's a
different kind of cult worship they
think if they have you elevated to a
person that's going to aggravate in
their mind so they assume that that's
what you're trying to even do that you
have math you've mastered that that
genre of tweet I gotta say but what did
I I didn't even do any I honestly was
not planning or thinking anything I saw
the tweet and I was like Superman's gay
and I tweeted it out foreign
coming from you you hardcore right-wing
extremist Trump Maga psychopath if you
say anything is gay you mean it's bad
not that they're actually two men having
sex that's uh that's how they perceive
it so let's know that so in fact he's
not by either you were wrong oh he's not
he's queer okay they say by now you've
likely heard he's that's more offensive
to me Superman champion of the oppressed
Man of Steel the man of Tomorrow the
last son of Krypton the Big Blue Boy
Scout Mister not a bird nor plane
himself okay that's all completely wrong
by the way this is his son uh fear all
of a sudden uh the the yeah the son of
kellel is not kalal so please guys get
your comic book stuff right they say
we're not talking about the classic
original Clark Ken blah blah we get it
to son Jonathan Kent whose precise
backstory in the comics has been so
ruthlessly pummeled by a series of
reboots retcon space missions time
traveler and Rapid aging as to render it
so incomprehensible that it sends even
die hards like me scurring to the
nearest Wiki if you you guys know that
pink Kryptonite turned superman gay what
what yes it was green there's a bunch of
different colors of kryptonite oh yeah
the pink one turns him gay I'm I'm that
that's just wait from like the 50s
Comics I'm pretty sure sounds like a
pentagon bio weapon
um that they talked about discussing and
implementing in Vietnam but that's
another story
deconstruction yeah here look Superman
Wiki pink Kryptonite is a type of
kryptonite that seemingly turns
kryptonians homosexual it is unknown
what it would do to an already
homosexual Kryptonian although one could
assume it would render them heterosexual
or just get tired of kryptonite only
made one appearance in the comics and
was used as a satire of the plots of the
Silver age comic stories featuring some
strange new form of kryptonite obscenely
offensive okay so that's from new
versions that's not from the old version
uh this is from Supergirl number 79 many
happy returns what year was this one
I don't I don't know I I don't know I I
genuinely I don't care about comic books
yeah but I understand why people do
you know these are like uh superheroes
or icons that would you know Batman for
instance Inspire P inspire you to like
you know Superman Never Kills the
villain he arrests them and now I guess
the the is there a concern I don't know
what your opinion is on this I don't
know what your opinion on this is Jack
about taking away the traditional
masculine role
at once I have the same reaction as you
do which is I don't care because I don't
think Comics are really that relevant
but I do know that there are a lot of
people that read them and that the
cultural influences are important but at
this point man it's just like the ocean
is around us and the pot is boiling and
I really don't know it didn't it didn't
like look it's like if this was the
first story that came out about the
first thing that was doing this maybe
but it's just like the million billion
thing that we've heard and so what I'm
saying is maybe I'm capitulating you
know a little bit my sensitivity has
been diminished to it but you know
honestly it doesn't really bother me but
I do I do disagree with the the
retconning right like the rewriting of
the stories these new characters yeah
and just make a new character right
Superman is Superman his son you well I
guess are they gonna set up the
storyline where Clark Kent gets upset by
this and he disowns the disowns Superboy
or whatever no it would be like like
Superman is super accepting and then Lex
Luthor gets mad or something you know uh
I did I did see an interesting critique
where someone's that Superman has always
been the progressive anyway right even
even the original Superman uh character
which I'm not familiar with I don't
remember the movies I don't read the
comics but I do recall there was some
instance in which he was like we want to
you know save everybody and help
everybody achieve this and bring you
know bring everybody up and you know
it's a very Progressive sort of sort of
mindset I think culturally I also think
we're kind of defunct in many different
ways because it's like we just keep
repeating the same stories over and over
again and to your point make a new
character yeah make something new make
something interesting but also a scream
is being redone home alone is being
redone yesterday two of those trailers
dropped I mean can't you think of new
movies I I here's how I imagine it
imagine a table like this and the DC
Comics people are sitting there and
they're like eyes half glazed over and
then they're just like uh look guys
um I gotta I got a masseuse waiting for
me can we just do something oh I know I
know um Superman but but
[Applause]
is boring and old but there's only so
many stories and they usually involve
archetypical situations in your life
like things that everybody goes through
there's coming of age you have like 50
genders there's so many different
options here that you can roll with
there's meetings there's meetings
they did this remember the Marvel comic
were safe they had safe space yeah new
New Mutants and it was yeah it crashed
and burned they pulled it well but but I
was looking to get an original copy of
it I can't find it oh that'd be awesome
I'm gonna finish my thought uh Coming of
Age meeting your girl uh having kids
getting divorced uh getting your new job
having your parents die having your
spouse die these are these are stories
that everyone can relate to so there's
always going to be stories about that
over and over and over and over and over
again uh I will say uh my I have a
daughter and you know you know crucify
me for letting my daughter watch Disney
but I will tell you that descendants is
actually pretty good The Descendants
movie is about like the kids of the
original Disney characters and they're
all their hijinks and uh you know the
music is good man there's a lot of very
crazy subliminal messaging and Disney
movies
um we can't even talk about it here I
don't know yeah it was apparently it was
the new Warriors not the New Mutants the
new Warriors yeah they had safe space
and snowflake yeah oh right that did
that was that so that actually get
released because I remember tweeting
about that I tweeted about the
characters and all this stuff new
Warriors subscribe to it but this is the
new new Warriors they're remaking the
new Warriors here and they they ended up
scrapping it because it was a little too
sjw are you sure yes is this right it's
from what I heard is it right here man
if you can get that please do it's 200
270 boxes that's pretty pricey whoa
there it is wait no 10 bucks
price anchoring like crazy wait wait I
can order a thousand
please don't you know my thoughts on
this are that creative expression you
can do whatever you want with creativity
I don't know why these particular people
are in control of the Superman franchise
right now I have to buy 25 apparents
definitely do it minimum orders 25. I
hope they don't want to get someone in
the house I hope they don't make
sexuality the topic of the Superman
comic because it's never been the
purpose of Superman his sexuality was
never the spotlight but if people feel
that being bisexual queer gay or
whatever makes it make sexuality there's
a love story but that wasn't the his
sexuality wasn't part of it it was about
the love between Lois and Clark
heteronormativity bro maybe someone's
taking a picture of him kissing a man
out of context and making it a bigger
deal than it is maybe the comic it's not
big a big part of the plot he just loves
this guy so let's find out but I I and I
made it that's a bigger deal than I
realized for the queer people that that
is a big part of the plot of being alive
and being real and that what what
actually I take offense to and are
hopefully we don't get banned for this
but like I I like queer is a political
perspective now
queer means to do you can be straight
and be queer
I didn't know this I'm learning this but
actually this is where are you learning
this year Jack you're you're technically
wrong that's one of those pit traps
where you're offensive no matter what
you say about it oh well of course yeah
yeah of course it's offensive but like
my point is that to be queer is now a
political position which means to blur
boundaries on purpose but but it's not
acceptable like like the the use of the
term is acceptable not acceptable at the
same time well right I'm not using a
derogatory no no no in any context like
that so women can't you can't say queer
I think you can it's LGBT it's right in
there you can't say I don't know what
I'm saying is the way you're describing
it as a political thing and you can be
straight but be queer that's not true
it's one of those things where you'll
see some people say it then as soon as
someone else has it it's offensive and
you get banned for it so like like
wimixon for instance was uh w-o-m-x-n
you know women but they say wimixin and
then they said this is the new inclusive
term and then immediately the the
organization that was using it started
getting canceled and attacked and then
you have you have activate the same time
the word web mixing is both
simultaneously inoffensive offensive of
and the appropriate term right which
means no matter what you say they will
come after you and then they will wage a
campaign against you when it comes to
cancel culture there's no logic for the
most part it's what can I do to get this
person hurt and so they've created
circumstances where no matter what
you're saying falling into a trap there
it's trap okay but but there are kids
teenagers who identify as queer who are
attracted to people of the opposite sex
and who also believe that they are the
gender matching the sexuality that they
were aside at their birth and and
there's no I said all that and there's
no way for you to properly address it
without getting banned well then I I'm
not addressing woke pit traps
yeah I mean look at Crowder that's what
we're talking about Stephen Crowder gets
gets nuked for talking about a news
story
these are treacherous times we live in
my friend but this is why we set up
timcast.com because at the very least
you know that's the way I put it when it
comes to like New York and the in the in
the vaccine mandate stuff if there was a
business that had a speakeasy in the
back that was operating saying you know
yeah yeah go in the back and we're not
mandating whatever I'd be like they're
clearly in opposition they're clearly
standing up against it or they could
sell ownership they can be like buy one
share of the company you can do whatever
you want on the property there you go
that could work so you got to have we
got we got to have a space a backup
space but I don't know man there's
there's there's simultaneously reasons
to be optimistic reason reasons to be
pessimistic you see there was a story
about the Republicans flipping a
democratic stronghold seat in Iowa yeah
I saw that moving one step closer to
taking control of many different uh
legislative bodies in the different
states and with Joe Biden's failing
approval rating we also have uh an organ
two organizations that raise money for
state-level Republicans record
fundraising Kevin McCarthy record
fundraising like 60 million bucks so I
mean
I think those are good indications of a
red wave that could be optimistic if
Republicans did anything yeah otherwise
it's just kind of like yeah good for
them I guess but what are we gonna get
out of it we're talking about 2022 all
of a sudden all of a sudden yeah I love
you guys well I'm just talking about
like you know seeing all the censorship
and having you know the private website
set up should I be optimistic that we're
gonna pull through and we're gonna we're
gonna be able to have these
conversations and continue to be honest
and open 100 man or are we going to lose
it
and I think a red wave at the very least
is a is a bump in the road yeah I don't
think the politics matter about
censorship because the the corporations
are in kind of in control and you got to
speak their language you got to speak
people's language in general people that
work at all echelons of Corporations I
think like polish like polish Luke
speaks Polish like Spanish French and
English I think that it's typical or at
least not unusual to have a change in
the Congressional control mid-year
elections so I wouldn't be surprised by
that happening I would love to have an
order in a conversation about lgbtq on
the after show on the show with people
from different you know sexual gender
feelings and and Lifestyles I think it'd
be incredible it'd be good for society
people are a lot more similar than we
realize than even I realized
I was at a a farm store
we got these little alpacas you see a
little little alpaca can you do you have
alpaca cam ready look at that little guy
so they make these uh the little alpaca
scarves are made from alpaca and I was
talking to these fine uh folks and this
is in Loudoun County and today Max and
they what is that with the next Louden
no folks folks oh yes definitely but
they were just like they're regular
people they're like not super political
but I was like you guys know James
o'keeffas and they're both like oh yeah
of course oh man you know my my
brother-in-law wouldn't travel about him
we're big fans and I was like wow
these are just regular people you know
they're not super into politics they
didn't know I was anything but they had
heard of James they knew about what's
going on and I think regular people
moderate independent types are very much
not in line with with the establishment
right now oh I agree with that 100 and I
think that this the the fight as uh
embodied in Loudoun County about uh CRT
and school districts and all the things
following on from there or like the the
number one red pill distribution
mechanism in America wokism coming to
your you know five-year-old classroom
people who aren't online who aren't you
know following the establishment
whatever all of a sudden they wake up
and they have to deal with these issues
uh with their kids in grade school and
that that brings them into the
conversation yeah what bothers me is
outside forces trying to twist The
Narrative when where it's coming from
like why inflame tensions between
Americans why who would why would
someone do that why do you why who would
sow chaos and dissent among other
citizens of Earth yeah in general why
would you that's so weird you torture
its prey are you being sarcastic no I'm
just it's a rhetorical question like I
know that there are reasons of it but so
they can continue to extract resources
from us
resources meaning what exactly money
time energy Capital everything
it's like the Matrix right little
batteries or inside of the Matrix I love
that question why does the cat torture
its prey why it's in its genetics
because it likes to watch it struggle
what or some creatures are just
inherently evil
the cats are evil I don't think being a
predator is naturally evil my dog just
like kills squirrels and possums and
rats and chipmunks and whatever and then
she still comes back and cuddles and is
nice to my kids so I don't know is she
evil for that no I'm a doctor is
something different I'm a dog I think
there's something different about
um
we could go the Crowder email was
actually about a video from September
30th I think Wicked about some a similar
issue not the most recent one he did but
the email is from today so I had the
date on it I assumed it was like them
directly responding based on the
conversation I was having but I believe
it was the video itself is actually
older The Alex Jones one so that makes
sense that was a couple weeks ago right
yeah but why that one
I watched that video was there anything
in it you noticed nothing stood out no
you see you see all of a sudden Ian's
like wait a minute hold on a second
wait it wasn't actually about the skid
of handing out condoms into all women's
prison maybe maybe that's probably
compounding because they were like it's
multiple times you've put people at odds
or whatever well how about we go to
super chats everybody if you haven't
already smash that like button me and
Luke are actually going to fight we
could do like a little uh skirmage
yeah he called me a cat guy I don't know
I've never been more insulted in my life
all right everybody we're gonna hit
that's uh get to the super chats so make
sure you go to timcast.com become a
member we have a members only segment
coming up later on usually around 11 or
so p.m let's see what we got all right
we got next pack saying paid for by
Shiba Inu love you guys I listen to your
news every day Tim keep up the truth
thank you for the big old Super Chat and
Shiba Inu coin interesting I'm not I'm
not a big fan necessarily but I read
about it I think it's it is interesting
the Sheba goal I guess is to be the
Dogecoin of ethereum
oh my God so the the most useless token
on the ethereum Chain basically but I
actually regular meme coin meme coin
popularity means a functioning viable
opportunity a coin that's you could have
the best coin in the world the best
utility token if nobody use it it's
worthless
you can get a functioning crypto that
becomes popular and then start building
things on it
it's true yep it's also pump and dump
scheme yeah I know that's why I'm not
I'm not a big fan of people being like
hey look at this queen all right let's
see we got here Herp Derp says Tim pool
trucker here the trucker shortage has
been going on for years what we're
seeing now is a Distribution Center
employee shortage trucks are backed up
for miles just when you get loaded whoa
yeah there's uh headlines in today's
news cycle that Biden is going to save
Christmas that's like saying a lunatic
saved someone after he stopped stabbing
them yeah it's ridiculous I mean it's
it's so freaking crazy Biden's going to
save Christmas are you kidding listen to
NPR on the way I listened to two things
on the way up here today I'm about an
hour away I listen to NPR and then I
listen to uh my boy Jack passovic on
human events human events daily I love
his motto uh be brief be good and be
gone or something like that yeah so uh
in both in both circuses they were
talking about how Biden Biden has now
the quote negotiated with the
longshoremen to work 24 7 you know to to
get them to unload all these shipping
containers to solve the problem
solve the problem he literally told them
they need to work more he was like Hey
FedEx UPS will work more that's his
solution yeah
are you frustrated with President Obama
oh yeah all right we got we got a board
one here uh-oh tacitus spankmore says oh
boy Jack you're skipping New York City
due to the max mandate but King County
Washington Seattle and the 30 40 mile
radius has vaccinated starting in two
weeks yeah I know uh we're contemplating
pulling the plug on Seattle for that
definitely do it yeah I hate Twitter I
hate to say it I want to come to Seattle
I I love the the geography uh uh and
some of the people I met there were or
do a civil disobedience picnic outside
of that venue like they're doing all
over Europe all over Europe there's
people when they Implement these vax
passports that are saying we're just
gonna go outside and eat the food
outside yeah totally except our plan to
go was like in the middle of winter so
cool
do you think George Washington
complained about the cold
Jack George Washington also implemented
vaccine mandates so I don't know what
you're talking about bro that's
interesting he's able to pull up right
there yeah we got an important one from
Miss Mary she says just commenting so
Tim knows he does have female listeners
I want to know more about that skin
pigment stuff you had on the cast castle
video
so in the Vlog we got a package of
BioTrust samples and one of them was
like I think it's called like Angel's
Beauty or something oh yeah and they
were like would you be interested in
shouting this out and I was just like I
don't know if it would be sincere like
if I could as a dude who doesn't use
this stuff like actually promotion Jack
would be perfect for it Jack if you're
looking for a sponsorship
we could get like headgear and Spar a
little bit I'm down I was looking for a
paintball party well so so anyway
paintball games yeah in the Vlog I said
I'm not sure that like our mostly male
audience is going to be interested in me
promoting like you know ageless skin
care products but apparently Miss Mary
saw it and she's interested now you
think the liminal order guys would want
to play paintball absolutely the cast
Castle versus lumino order let's do it
yeah you know let's do a paintball
battle we've got like legit tier one
doesn't matter we got professional
larpers super ripped dudes in full
tactical gear like walking through the
forest and it's like Ian
I'm interested you have to I need a nice
automatic paintball
are your demographics I mean I presume
that they're a majority male but are
they like is it like 90 10 or yeah
something like that I'd be down to do
this uh ageless Beauty I'd rub it on my
face on on air
all right that's a different video by
the end of the show
she puts the cream on her face it's
probably really good for your skin all
right Matthew Vance says Tim massive
respect for your work and opinions but
regarding your criticisms of mandate
compliance is it comparable to complying
to background checks when you oppose all
gun laws apples and oranges or not in
your opinion what I mean is if people
are saying vaccine mandates for
employment are wrong and now I'm going
to actively engage in that specifically
they're not actively opposing the
Mandate they're participating in it you
can still dislike it and say I don't
want it to exist so I'll say this if
you're claiming that you are opposing
it's a semantic it's a semantic
confusion if you say I don't think we
should have background checks for guns
then you can still be like I'm gonna
vote for that but if in the meantime
that I understand if you're saying that
I I you know don't like vaccine mandates
but for the time being I'll vote for
that and then you keep complying my
problem there is that compliance has
only made the whole problem worse so
they're not they're not necessarily one
for one but I will say okay this is the
point I've been making if you are still
a part of a system like in New York like
if you're opening a restaurant and you
have a big sign in the window saying
vaccines required but then back in the
back there's a back door where speakeas
is happening you are clearly actively in
opposition to the vaccine mandates if
you get your CCW so you don't have to go
through the background check process
anymore like okay well now you're there
there's means to say I will not
participate in that I will use an
alternative and there's also
um I don't know exactly what's going on
and maybe I shouldn't say too much
considering you know it's a firearm
issue but there are other means of you
know working within the law and um
directly opposing things like background
checks or Nicks
but um you'll have to work that one out
for yourself because I don't want to you
know give anybody advice or anything
necessarily on legal issues I don't know
about you know what I mean but there's
like there's stuff you can do with like
ffls and with concealed carry that if
you have a concealed carry permit in
West Virginia you don't need a
background check
so you quite literally just get your
concealed carry and then you can just
walk in any store you want and they
don't track a recording of this stuff
but anyway all right let's see we got
Mike Sullivan says love the show and the
castle Vlogs congrats on your new studio
last night daily wire sold at an
Auditorium in Nashville 2 800 people
chanting let's go Brandon nice very nice
let's go Brandon
all right let's see what we got here
we got a comment I saw a question
someone questioned the memetic value of
let's go Brandon do you think that that
escapes the just the very online and has
contagion like capabilities I know it's
a meme but I'm saying like is it is it
can it can it be contagious or is it
really just isolated to people that
happen to catch that particular story on
I think it's I think it's one of the
most powerful things we've ever seen
let's go Brandon to the average
unsuspecting person is this a silly fun
chant they might engage in yeah I
remember when I was down during Occupy
Wall Street Luke knows this people would
start chanting Antica pizzalista and I
remember I don't know if you were there
with me Luke but some guy was going ah
yeah
like and I was like what would you say
and he goes huh and I'm like what are
you chanting and he goes oh I'm just
chanting and I'm like what are you
saying oh I'm just I don't know I'm just
they were literally chanting gibberish
because they didn't know the chant was
ah on TI Antica Pita Lista and so they
were just making gibberish up to gend
along with it so if you get a bunch of
people chanting let's go Brandon right
the media will be like all of these
people are doing the right wing Meme and
then they'll start reporting there's a
big surge I remember I started chanting
I really want pizza
and and let's go Brandon shirt one of
the best sellers on our t-shirt store
right now so uh there's a lot of
popularity there's a URL for that the
best politicalshirts.com that's a good
one you should go there and appreciate
that guy asking me questions about
Seattle and acknowledging no vaccinated
he's clearly been to jackbrunch.com
where you can find out all of the
information on the jack brunch tour
including all the dates and the
Eventbrite uh sales brunches are awesome
they really are Jay Lopez says Jimmy
kimball
I don't care
that's why we love Luke kenjin Ranger
says Ian is literally calling for
censorship let's go Ian I can't believe
oh I can't believe people are okay with
censorship dude hasn't even watched
Stephen Crowder I was a sensor for
social media for five years and I
understand the value of judicious
censorship
so you admit it I'm not going to pretend
like it's bad all the time and we need
to get rid of all censorship because
then it's just pure chaos and nothing
can get done Ian Ian is correct there is
good censorship it's true
we we don't want Gore and violence and
murder and illegal content we need
someone who's going to filter through
that stuff and get and remove it from
these platforms the problem is when they
start saying oh but political content is
also offensive so no no I wish I could
remember the name of it but one of my
good friends produced a uh play but it
happened during covet so they turned it
into an audio play which is very
interesting uh about what it's like to
be a reviewer
that that has to manually review this
kind of content that you just described
murder Gore these type of things and
what it does psychologically oh my gosh
to the reviewer who just 24 well not 24
but seven days a week all not even seven
days
eight hours a day is just looking at the
most what's really bad is when you see a
lot of it in a short period of time
remember the Christ Church shooting that
guy went with a headcan like a GoPro on
and killed a bunch of people outside of
two mosques and I kept seeing the video
over and over and over and different one
guy had the Doom the video game Doom
overlay over like it was a video game
and it started to really like I I can't
put words I can't use words to describe
it because the memories and stuff like
the way it's you remember the past it's
like those things become memories and
and when you see the bodies like and the
people that are I can't Tim I can't go
into it I know you don't want I can't
you can't
it's just it's a it's for these people
this is their job you got to understand
so I think people can get triggered when
Stephen Crowder or anyone starts to step
over the line because it triggers all
these other things you see is so far
removed from what you're describing what
happens it triggers
um other their memories of those other
things that they've seen I don't care I
literally don't just want you want to be
a whiny cry baby you can't handle it's
not whining
a soldier sees his friends die that is
who said that dude enough look okay
enough we're talking about a guy who
does a comedy show you're trying to act
like it's a mass shooting no I'm
thinking no I'm saying that as an admin
when you see people start to cross the
line it can trigger like other things
that you've seen in the past
let's read some more Super chats
all right let's see we got here
Angela lucarelli says in the animal
kingdom the males are larger heavier and
stronger than the females defect except
for hyenas I think I think there's more
animals where that's not the same yeah
there's a fish where the females are
massive and the males are tiny and they
latch on and then become parasites and
then just live on the body it's gross
but I think generally speaking
especially among mammals
that's the case
Anthony Eppley says Tim when can we
expect you and Jack to co-sponsor an
event I don't know all right let's do
another event let's do it Tim love the
idea when November we'll figure it out
let's do it we'll do it awesome that
sounds fun yeah we actually assume Jack
would be at the event we were doing but
then we found out he was doing his own
thing I think it would be cool to do a
music event with Eric July and Ari the
rugged Man that's personally
let's do it
there's a lot of opportunity Nets says I
think Ian's doppelganger is Chris
Pontius from jerk every time I see him I
have a banana hammock flashbacks PTSD
I can kind of see Chris Pontius yeah I'm
still learning who this guy is
Kevin McMahon says Tim fellow Chicago in
here the railroads have implemented the
December 8th deadline for the vax and I
and many other will be standing our
ground so if you think the planes are
bad wait till the trains stop moving and
your food ain't coming in you see Jack
uh Augustine Farms announced on their
website you can't order anymore
really and they do the emergency food
stuff there's a viral viral letter going
around where they're telling one of
their clients they can't Pride with
supplies anymore like they can't Supply
them so it looks like they're they're
pulling back due to Major shortage so
that's emergency food when the emergency
Foods you can't get good good thing
there's 18 years of beans here right 18
are you joking sorry 50 30. probably 100
each bin is 30 years
they last 30 years but considering how
many people we have here I think it's
like two weeks to a month oh dang yeah
we got 30 people
you're right we'll fire everybody kick
him out when it hits the fan yes and
then the beans are all mine no one else
well exactly right can I stay you know
pulling into the driveway Tonight I
almost ran over three Bambi's I hit the
brakes
and uh I guess if this you know happens
I'll just
they were stealing our fruit Jack the
dude they come in they eat all our
Persimmons you know I I had a mini
little farm on my uh property when a few
years ago and I grew all kinds of
vegetables and stuff and I had this
beautiful crop of broccoli and they'd
grown out of the ground and the heads
were just big and I was getting ready
the next day to go out and clip them all
off I come out they're all gone of
course the deer found them and they just
destroyed my entire crop so
[Music]
in the first segment though but the
story that Crowder in trouble was about
a women's prison specifically ah and
then they did a skit and they were you
know attacked for it or YouTube came
down on them for it so my understanding
I made a mistake I think based on what
we were talking about it was this
loudness story I do think that ties into
the loud and story too though because
they were it was a similar kind of
although yeah you're right but but if
the strike was from an older video yeah
you know I wonder if they saw today's
story I was like uh we'll get we got him
all right let's see twine I want to know
what does it take to get like a direct
connection to YouTube like that where
their lawyers are talking to your
lawyers well there's a certain threshold
there there's a lawsuit between Crowder
and YouTube no I don't know I believe
there is I believe they were talking
about it so obviously when you have
lawyers talking back and forth that
would be the relationship yeah I mean
I've got a contact at Google
so like we launched a new show Tales
from the inverted world and I'm like hey
heads up we're going to be applying for
monetization someone get in touch with
this man Jack's ready
take the breaks off my channel would you
by the way Jack Murphy live on YouTube
new videos every day imagine that oh I
got a correction here another correction
unspecial noobs as Tim Brazilian
sprinkle Yucca flower not cornmeal on
their beans and rice Source I live in
Brazil for a couple of years later
married to Brazilian also busy food is
freaking amazing especially Northeastern
Brazilian food dude what is it called
churrasco is that what it is yeah that
was good is that when they come with all
the big things of meat churrasco is a
form of painting
what yeah I don't think you're right I
thought you were talking about a pastry
what's the meat pastry the thing about
it I don't know what I'm talking about
pretty good what's it called where uh
look it up Brazilian Brazilian barbecue
yeah Brazilian Grill they they walk
around with big skewers with massive
hunks of meat churrasco churrasco
traditional churrasco
you were wrong pepper onion you're wrong
maybe it's something fired spelled
differently they comps your plate with a
knife and they cut the meat off right
onto your plate not that we should get
one we can get one of those those like
rotisserie things and they're walking
around and you'll see like the the pork
guy in your life can we go to one before
the broccoli they have these all over
the United States we're on your table
you just put there's a little disc it's
a gr it's a green on one side red on the
other and when it's green the guy with
the meat they all come to your table
there's like 20 different kinds of meats
and they all come they just pile it on
and if you're if you just want to pause
you just turn it over and it's red and
that way they don't hassle you wow yeah
I also love conveyor belt Sushi that's
so much fun yeah and in Japan they have
a race race car on a track Sushi where
you have a little thing and you type in
what you want and a car drives the food
to you and then you just take it off the
thing and then press the button it goes
back sounds fun nice and then you put
your plates on it and then it sends out
more food it's so awesome on conveyor
belt do you just take it off when you
want it and they charge you every time
you pick Yeah by plate yeah the color
plates and green plates and so it's just
it's great because you're sitting there
like nope nope nope
no that's how you feed it and then
someone made a viral video I put the
GoPro on it let's put their phone on it
Fogo de Chao that's what it is the place
with the red and green discs come on all
right twine autist says as an Alaskan
Alaska is terrible it's dark by 3 P.M
and around zero degrees Fahrenheit for
nine months a year it's too cold to grow
most foods during the short summer we
wouldn't make it if there was a collapse
huh can't you eat like elk or something
or moose Bears yeah eat bears don't eat
you I've watched Homestead rescue I know
you can build a green house and extend
your growing season up there but but I'm
only going moving to Alaska at the end
of climate change is real
just just you go uh you you eat bear you
just I'm gonna just eat bear that's just
sit there it's so obvious you should
wrestle him down there I'm gonna get the
carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere
wire so thanks bro are polar bears South
or North I think they're North are they
North yeah yeah Arctic are they uh
protected I think they might be
protected oh okay then don't eat animals
won't matter if the world's ending what
about penguins can you can you eat
penguins also protected I don't know
this is outside my purview I would never
eat it you know they're a penguin in
like chili I think right yeah oh yeah
I've been I've been to Antarctica
actually really yeah no way actually too
and what are you doing down there I
stood on the shore with 250 million
Penguins or I'm sorry 250 000 Penguins
just to go be with the Penguins yes wow
just to go to Antarctica there's no
other reason to go I wasn't like there
wasn't a hot new restaurant
obviously if you want to enter the
hollow Earth you got to go to you guys
there's so many conspiracies that just
started right now
[Laughter]
and inside the earth too yeah have you
ever seen that image where there's like
a conspiracy theory that the North and
the South Pole are holes oh and you walk
in and then gravity inverts I guess yeah
because more masses on the bottom and
you can see a sun in the middle and then
you can see past the sun is other ground
I guess because you're inside the hollow
Earth
Ian and you on this the classified magma
people come up with funny stuff I'll
tell you this it's interesting all right
let's see I think Alaska would be hold
on if you ever a Journey to the Center
of the Earth by Jules Verne oh yeah good
luck classic
non-fiction yeah that's right oh my gosh
it's a documentary
Aldo Pineda says I believe the 600 Banks
spying is to Target those fired for not
complying to [ __ ] them even more they
have declared war on freedom loving
Patriots so you gotta be a special
person if you believe them when they're
like
spying on accounts with at least 600
taxes the rich what what are they
talking about you're talking about
taxing the poor this person was going
after the side hustle sometimes yeah
someone's like if I bought a couch
two years ago for twelve hundred dollars
and now and next year I want to sell it
for 800. are they gonna tax me on that
yeah on that depreciation this is really
a surveillance bill that Janet Yellen is
literally arguing this will make sure
that the billionaires pay their taxes
that's literally what she just said and
that's the most disingenuous craziest
thing that I have ever heard yeah it's a
lie and you've heard many things you've
said many of similar things here right
here that I was a cat man first of all
are you a cat man I am not a cat man
I don't know I would be full but you
know but who knows
hey you know we all have a role to play
on this show do you have pets I have a
dog
Rosie she makes an appearance on every
show Jack Murphy live on YouTube you can
hear that or get the audio download as
well you got to meet Rosie every day I
feel I record it I'm pretty sure I heard
a meow in one of those shut up I do it
live at noon every day and approximately
around not every day but mostly and then
around one o'clock the mailman shows up
and Rosie goes Bonkers there you go no
she's probably like cats I'm a cat guy
Shane Lagan says love the show love the
studio love Luke is back and so is Jack
as a former competitive motocross racer
it pains me to see the trouble y'all are
having to get the bike to go elbows up
always we got two dirt bikes and um I
think one's like a 185 one's like a 220
Cc or whatever they're big and one of
them is uh I just was very it was easy
for me to start you know pull the clutch
hit it shift and then drive the other
one wasn't going and then I just kept I
don't know what I was doing so they
filmed me struggling to make the bike go
and I just said whatever I got we got
the electric ones to go so uh we got
free damastan and we're looking to
um do a survey of the property tomorrow
afternoon so
um there's still some stuff we're
working with with the previous owners
they're still there for the time being
but we're gonna go there and probably
just take the electric off-road bikes
and go through the woods and everything
and all right just take a look at the
property what do you mean elbows up like
this
yeah like that I have no idea maybe like
that when you're ready for a long time
since I read one I'm not a Motocross
keep your elbows bent one time I did a
jump and have my elbows straight like
that and like [ __ ] they like shocked
back in
we went to uh we went to Travis
Pastrana's place a couple weekends ago
that was amazing it's crazy I just got a
text Ian from uh red and my fiance and
she said she told she's telling me to
tell you that we did grounding last week
she made me go out in the front yard
stand in my bare feet in the grass to
recharge with the Earth's magnetic
forces I was doing that today uh as I
was dead lifting I just had a vision
last night of getting my mother it's
been I haven't seen my mom in a year and
a half but when I do I'm going to hug
her and when I do it I'm gonna ground
her energy into the Earth's core and
into the Stars you can actually also
send the energy into the stars and you
can kind of conduit it through you and
then it's just that's a real hug you
know that 135 ago Dude
how's that 1 35 today did a workout did
you get it up uh what are you talking
about you're a dead lift 135. I don't
know exactly what I was doing I was just
dead lifting oh okay but it was it was
it was strenuous 100 135 grams yeah yeah
he struggles I wasn't counting maybe I
broke a sweat is it on the Vlog let's
see it there might be yeah
all right DJ Madero says we need to at
least go back to the moon it's a rather
strange satellite that no one can
adequately explain how it came to orbit
the earth except for an astronomically
improbable Collision theory that some
astrophysic physicists say needed to
happen twice
other planetoid uh in the early Earth's
solar system 3.6 billion years ago or
something smashed through earth and its
orbit came out the other side as a ball
of magma slowly cooled maybe it came
back and then threw again I don't know
how does a asteroid go through a planet
without destroying the planet it
completely turned it into both like
liquid when it went through liquefied
both and then they slowly most of the
earth came out on the other side and
then became the Moon is the theory and
it cooled and apparently it's Hollow
it's like a hollowish ball of magma that
what and so it's like the moon probably
open space
I was thinking about probing it inside
it but even if we probe the center of
the Moon we might end up killing
whatever's in there if there's life so
we got to be real careful about going
down there life inside them I don't know
Roz's rotary rescue says Crowder's video
from today was removed as well I watched
it early this afternoon now it's gone
maybe part of the strike as well
could be my understanding from you know
what we were what I was being told was
that it was particularly about what
happened in Loudon though maybe maybe
I'm incorrect
or maybe it was you know a big scoop up
all right let's see TJ fippin says Tim
Cass should start a monthly quarterly
box include one of the Thousand weird
comics and our pillow your own beverage
holder I'm down take my money Tim PS sup
Ian sup dog TJ working on the fediverse
headspace as Ian have you considered
testosterone supplementation Alex Jones
can hook you up do the world a favor I
have actually and I've also noticed I
think people can take too much tea you
see the really red face people
um so you got to kind of balance that
out are you trying to single someone out
here John McAfee I love you but I think
you were too high tea I had a great idea
I wanted to hire a Fitness and Nutrition
expert to come and help all of the
people at the cast Castle to eat better
and to to make sure they're getting in
some exercise every day and I thought I
was just imagining what would happen if
we like hired some like super ripped
like Jim bro and then imagining like in
five months every single employee of the
castle is just like super ripped and
wearing like tank tops and like this
should not be a fan
I want you to imagine Ian super ripped
massive chest exactly as he is but just
mad fish we take before and after photos
and then start hacking supplements right
afterwards yeah it's a huge business I
think this should be a business part of
the business plan that's my personal
opinion you can leave the hot pants in
the pink tank tops outside but I you
know if you did that I would strongly
support that 100 contribute anywhere
that I could no but I I seriously do
think that we we should you know I I
would I would like to get someone who
specializes in nutrition to do the snack
shopping so we can cut out the garbage I
haven't beaten sugar no sugar for uh
like I think it's like we're only two
months now I'm eating mostly meats and
fats and been eating a whole lot
healthier now and I feel better and I'm
like we should have someone actually can
plan this out and then maybe just like
prepare meals like a chef that does it
all but also Fitness for sure they
should have on the show Alexander Cortez
he's got a really large Twitter
following he is an absolute Fitness God
he's got long beautiful hair just like
you you guys could swap stories on how
to maintain that Sheen he'll come here
and get you guys Cortez he's good he's
good you should have them on yeah I keep
getting messaged by will not keep but uh
health and fitness people that want to
join so I think if you're out there
message jobs at timcast.com you do
cooking Health all that stuff being
happy and healthy is active resistance
in today's day and age so is it a dead
lifting 135 grams that's right Blake
Smith says did you guys catch Logan's
interview with Dr Sanjay Gupta not yet
ready he did it no yeah he did uh I'm
hearing a lot of chatter about that
because he is directly implicating Dr
fauci and the gain of function studies
and he's talking about the exact uh you
know cleavage site right that they were
working on that is related to the
sickness that has been going around
everywhere so that this is a big
interview I'm getting a lot of
notifications I haven't seen it yet I
don't know the exact implications I'm
just reading some of the headlines that
I'm hearing seeing about it right now
wow yeah I'm looking at uh from msn.com
Rogan asked Sanjay Gupta fauci's quote
being honest about NIH connection to
Wuhan Labs getting a function so it's
out there
cleavage all right let's see
don't get too happy there Jack I'm glad
they're bringing that word Sonny James
says okay the surveillance thing with
the 600. if you had a crazy subscriber
that does something God forbid really
illegal would that give you a conspiracy
charge the motives behind our government
is terrifying uh I don't know how that
would function I don't understand what
that means the 600 thing the
surveillance thing they're basically
saying if you have an account with at
least 600 bucks they're gonna get your
your income and outgoing Revenue what
they're trying to do is if you lose your
job and you're like I'm gonna mow Lawns
for money they're gonna be like hey we
couldn't help but notice that money came
into your account that was unreported
can you explain it
they're taxing the pool if you buy
something that's been taxed and then you
resell it you get taxed again on it
that's right it's so messed it up if I
give you a dollar you got to pay taxes
you then take that I guess what you'd
have 93 78 78 78 cents or whatever 70 no
70 72 I guess up to ten thousand
I'm saying I'm saying like just in
general for like income if I say Ian I'm
gonna hire you to give me a high five
for one dollar then you end up getting
only like 72 cents then you say hey look
I'm gonna hire you you know hire you at
75 72 cents to do a high five then Luke
ends up with only like 50 cents so that
dollar goes around the table and then
the government's extracting like like
some kind of vampire just sucking the
currency of every transaction
it's not the way we're supposed to be
built I did read about a new app I did
read about a new app that takes your
Bitcoin holding and then uh you can just
swipe your card anywhere and it
automatically takes your Bitcoin holding
and converts it into USD just for that
transaction wow
that's a good step that's a good step I
wish I could remember what it is I'm
they're gonna kill me for not
remembering the name I think we just
need prices to be in Bitcoin
or maybe I don't know something else
yeah
all right let's see we got here Hugh
Beaumont says Tell Jack and Ian Teddy
says hi what's up Teddy what's up Teddy
oh by the way that's get swipe at
g-e-t-s-w-y-p-e
go to my Twitter profile and click on
the link there I get a referral amazing
my friends smash the like button if you
haven't already and go to timcast.com
become a member we got a a bonus member
segment coming up at around 11 or so p.m
at Tim pm at timcast.com we're also
going to start doing the tales from the
inverted World members only segment soon
and we're also going to have special
members only content from cast Castle
Vlog as well which is usually just you
know people hanging out whatever and
we're also going to be starting up the
Green Room which will be a Friday show
because right now we do Monday through
Thursday as the bonus segment now we're
going to have Fridays after the show The
Green Room show it'll be once a week
we're trying to figure out how to make
it work without you know going too much
in this space making something new and
unique and because we don't have
anything on Friday nights that's what
we'll do so make sure you check that out
you can follow the show at timcastirl or
underscore IL or whatever it is you can
follow me at timcast I hear Jack has
something going on I do first of all if
you believe in masculinity Brotherhood
and sovereignty and you're looking for a
group of men to get together and help
you change the world join terminal order
that's liminal hyphen order.com and if
you're just a regular person not a man
woman child anybody who wants to come to
our Sunday Fellowship events called Jack
brunch please do come jackbrunch.com our
next event is in Nashville on 10 24.
we've already got a ton of people signed
up and registers so please come check it
out a lot of fun what about you guy so I
could link a lot of my social media but
one of the most important things you
could do to make me uncensorable is to
sign up on my free email list and you
could very easily do that on enough of
censorship.com enough of censorship.com
and I give giveaways free content from
Luke uncensored and a lot of other
special prizes they're given out there
so I hope you guys sign up and get away
from the big Tech monopolies you can
also follow me on social media at Ian
Crossland that's mine's Twitter
Instagram and YouTube
um I noticed with the after show that
we're shooting tonight last night we did
it at higher resolution so the upload
and um encoding took a little bit longer
that's right I think that it wasn't
actually ready till about midnight so
maybe it'll be up at 11 Maybe might be a
little late but we'll find out it's
still a higher resolution so but we
reduced the the frame rate a little bit
uh something yeah so it might be a
little late if it is you know we'll
figure it out and we'll keep moving and
uh with the time there catch you later
pretty cool and I did want to say before
we go that I was not incorrect about
this word that Tim and I were talking
about we were just talking about
different languages I was talking about
Italian which is churroscuro chiaroscuro
which I said Roscoe
you're talking about Brazilian I was
talking about the painting which is like
the treatment of light and shade and
drawing and painting which is something
that John Rubens did a lot in his
paintings
anyways it's true
um I just want to say I'm Sarah
patchlitz on Twitter you guys are more
than welcome to follow me there we will
see all of you over at timcast.com in
the members segment thanks for hanging
out bye guys